Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio mit der Nummer 288 und zum ersten.
Chaos Radio im Jahr 2024 zu einem
Thema, das einerseits ganz alt ist und andererseits auch ganz aktuell.
Es geht um Hacker in Filmen und Hackerinnen.
Vielleicht auch das werden wir sozusagen genauer ergründen müssen.
Also es geht darum, wie die Menschen, über die wir hier im Chaosradio häufiger
sprechen, dargestellt werden in einem fiktiven Medium, das in unser aller Alltag
eine sehr, sehr große Rolle spielt.
Und der besondere Anlass dafür ist, dass jemand, also hat keinen Film vielleicht
schon mal gehört, ganz explizit geschaut hat, wie ist es eigentlich im deutschen
Bewegtbild, um diesen Namen an dieser Stelle auch mal sagen zu können.
Und deswegen sind wir heute sehr viele Menschen hier, zum Beispiel Konstanze
Kurz. Hallo und guten Tag. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich weiß ja mal nicht, als was bist du eigentlich hier? Bist du jetzt als Pressesprecherin
des TCC oder Redakteurin von Netzpolitik.org oder als freischaffende Hackerfilm-Guckerin
oder als was bist du heute hier?
Ich habe viele Hüte, such dir irgendwie einen aus. Ich bin hier als Hacker.
Na, ich möchte natürlich die große Gravitas mit ins Gespräch bringen und sagen,
herzlich willkommen, Konstanze Kurz, Pressesprecherin des Chaos Computer Clubs.
Wir nennen uns explizit nicht Pressesprecher, sondern Sprecherin.
Achso. Gut, wir gehen zur nächsten Vorstellung über Edith hier ausartet.
Ja, Frau Sprecherin, vielleicht wollen Sie das übernehmen.
Ich freue mich ganz besonders, dass wir William Mayhem hier haben.
Der ist zugeschaltet aus Arizona.
Er ist auch ein Amerikaner und er hat ein Buch geschrieben, was wir heute so
ein bisschen als Anlass haben, um über das Thema deutscher Hacker und die Darstellung
von Hackern in Filmen zu sprechen.
Und William unterrichtet Deutsch an der Northern Arizona University.
Ich habe mal ein bisschen nachgeguckt, das ist eine relativ große Uni mit 28.000
Studierenden, also eine ganze Menge.
In der Nähe vom Grand Canyon und deswegen auch touristisch beliebt, wie wir gehört haben.
Und er macht aber eben nicht nur Deutsch, sondern auch Literatur,
Kultur und unter anderem auch Filme.
Und so ist vielleicht auch dieses Buchprojekt entstanden. Und der ist halt,
würde ich mal sagen, ein Ziniast, kann man das sagen? Stimmt der Duell?
Ja, das stimmt. Vielen Dank für die Vorstellung.
Ich bin ganz gespannt, hier auf eurem Podcast zu sein und mit euch zu sprechen.
Und ja, genau, ich bin Professor von Germanistik.
Und das heißt, ich schreibe über deutschen Filmen, Wie zum Beispiel über die
von Christian Petzold und ich schreibe über Literatur eigentlich alles,
von dem Mittelalter bis zur Jetztzeit.
Also ich liebe deutsche Kultur und was du gesagt hast, die Universität hier
ist relativ groß, vielleicht ungefähr so groß wie die Universität Leipzig.
Und wir hören schon, bevor wir zu unserem nächsten Gast kommen,
du sprichst also sehr gut Deutsch, aber du hast auch hier eine Zeit verbracht.
Also du warst auch in Europa und speziell auch in Deutschland schon mehrfach zu Besuch.
Genau, ich war mehrmals in Berlin, ich habe da Freunde und ich habe auch ein
Jahr in Münster verbracht und Englisch an der WWU unterrichtet.
Ich würde noch ein kleines Detail nachreichen wollen.
Das Buch, was hier gerade angesprochen wurde, heißt Hackers as Heroes in German Film and Television.
Das gibt es schon seit Ende letzten Jahres, glaube ich, auf Englisch in den
USA und erscheint jetzt auch in Deutschland, aber auch auf Englisch.
Richtig? Richtig, genau. Ja, richtig.
Okay, und dann der vierte im Bunde heute ist jemand, den ich vorher nicht gefragt
habe, wie er heißen will, was ich eigentlich immer mache. Nickname oder richtiger Name?
Ähm, suchst du dir aus?
Ich habe mich ja vorhin für hochoffizieuse Gravitas entschieden.
Dann herzlich willkommen der Kulturwissenschaftler Kaspar Clemens Mierau. Hallo.
Spezialexperte muss man schon sagen für Hackerfilme, oder? Genau,
Spezialexperte für Hackerfilme. Kasper kennt ihr vielleicht aus dem Internet als Leitmedium.
Dort bloggt, socialt und macht der Hund.
Könnte man glaube ich so zusammenfassen. Und hatte vor einer Weile mal zumindest,
habe ich das so wahrgenommen, auch als eine der Interessenspunkte eben Hacker in Filmen.
Das hat angefangen, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, einfach als Liste.
Und er hat dann ins Rabbit Hole dich hineingeführt.
Ja, genau, das war 2007. Ich glaube, das war durch mein Studium.
Ich habe ja Medienwissenschaft studiert, Medienkulturwissenschaft und fand das spannend,
wie Bildschirme in Bildschirmen eigentlich dargestellt werden und habe einfach
eine ganz stumpfsinnige Liste gemacht und das hat sich dann verselbstständigt
und zu Podcasts und anderen Blogbeiträgen geführt und einmal auf dem Chaos Kongress
einen Vortrag und das bleibt bis heute Thema, aber es hat ein bisschen eingeschlafen bei mir.
Deswegen habe ich mich sehr gefreut buch dazu in die hand zu nehmen
vielleicht das als erste frage sagen ist es eingeschlafen
weil wie es manchmal im leben so ist die interessenslagen verändern
sich und jetzt mache ich lieber kaffee oder was auch immer oder es ist eingeschlafen
weil das thema eigentlich zu ende besprochen ist ich dachte dass das thema zu
ende besprochen sei weil das kam die generation von transformers filmen wo plötzlich
auch hacker eine rolle spielten und irgendwie.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass das auserzählt ist, das Thema. Es gab auch Lisbeth
Salander, hieß sie, glaube ich, in der Millennium Trilogie.
Das war sehr wichtig für Hacker in Filmen. F. D. Gerson.
Genau. Und dann dachte ich so, ja, jetzt suchst du dir ein anderes Hobby.
Und deswegen ist das gut, das jetzt aber nochmal sozusagen nochmal drüber nachzudenken
und auch mit dieser Außenansicht, über die wir gleich sprechen. Ja, okay.
Warte, ich muss noch eins fragen. Bist du auch ein Cineast? Würdest du das von
dir selber sagen? Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich mag das Wort nicht.
Ich denke aber gerne über Filme nach. Aber bei mir im Studium gab es so Filmnerds
und da habe ich mich nicht dazu gezählt.
Ich finde auch, das ist ein Wort, das hat so dieses Hochtrabende mit in sich.
Also ich entnehme dem Filmliebhaber ja, Snob nein.
Ja, natürlich bin ich dann wahrscheinlich doch Snob, aber ja. Ja, okay.
Okay. Ich würde, also wir reden ja jetzt gleich wahrscheinlich eine längere
Zeit über die fiktive Darstellung von HackerInnen.
Und damit wir vielleicht besser über die Unterschiede reden können,
also zwischen Fiktion und ich mache jetzt sozusagen, ich setze das in Klammern
und Anführungszeichen, so viel es geht, Wirklichkeit.
Vielleicht könnt ihr alle, und das hätte ich gerne von jedem von euch wirklich
einzeln, einmal sagen, Was ist ein Hacker oder eine Hackerin?
Also wenn ihr eine Person als Hacker oder Hackerin bezeichnet, was meint ihr damit?
Was bringt das für euch zum Ausdruck in einer realen Person?
Constanze, vielleicht kannst du anfangen.
Das ist aber nicht günstig, wenn ich anfange, weil ich natürlich darüber auch sehr oft rede.
Und weil ich eine bin. Also das ist ja nochmal ein Unterschied,
glaube ich. Das ist doch umso besser, dann kannst du mit einer Selbstbeschreibung
anfangen. Wieso bist du eine Hackerin?
Ich würde mit einer Sache beginnen. Ich habe, wie alle Menschen,
als ich im Studium war, immer Hacken sehr stark mit Programmiersprachen verbunden.
Und als ich dann das erste Mal so Live-Hacker traf, das war mein erstes und
bestes Informatikstudium, war aber mein erstes Projekt im CCC,
hatte überhaupt nichts mit Programmieren zu tun oder mit Programmiersprachen,
sondern war so Hardware.
Hast du schon eins dran gemocht? Als ich Hacker traf, warum hast du die so genannt?
Also warum nennst du die so? Was sind Hacker?
Nein, in meinem Fall war das so, dass ich die Uni, wo ich Informatik studiert
habe, die war halt direkt neben dem CCC, direkt neben dem Chaos Computer Club
und wir haben unsere Hausaufgaben gemacht, die wir so zwangsweise hatten.
Und ich fand interessant, dass mein erster Eindruck von Hackern damals war,
dass die halt gar nichts mit Programmieren oder so zu tun haben,
sondern dass sie viel mit Hardware zu tun hatten. Ich wollte nur den Begriff erweitern.
Während ich die Idee, dass Hacker irgendwas anderes machen, als Software gar nicht kannte.
Deswegen, wenn ich einen Hacker beschreiben würde, würde ich immer nicht nur
über Software, sondern auch über Hardware und alles Mögliche,
was man in seiner Form beeinflussen kann, sprechen wollen.
Deswegen habe ich es erwähnt.
Und vielleicht auch, weil ich selber sehr wenig mit Programmiersprache mache.
Ich muss das natürlich lernen, was man im Studium lernt, aber ich habe mich
immer mehr für Hardware interessiert.
Moment mal, also du sagst, Hacker sind Menschen, die digitale Dinge in Hard-
und Software beeinflussen und verändern?
Oh, das ist eigentlich eine ganz hübsche Definition. Meistens so diese Grenzen austesten, genau.
Okay, okay. Kasper?
Ich gehe da mit. Ich würde es noch ein bisschen weiterfassen.
Mir ist gerade eingefallen, während du über digital gesprochen hast,
ich glaube von Kevin Mitnick gibt es, glaube ich, dem berühmten Hacker,
gibt es in seiner Biografie diese Geschichte, wie er als Kind die Straßenbahnfahrscheine
gehackt hat, indem er die nachgelocht hat.
Und das ist ja jetzt nicht digital im Sinne von, also da fließt kein wirklicher Strom durch.
Deswegen würde ich es erweitern um eine bestimmte Denkweise,
dass man also versucht, für mich ist ein Hacker jemand, der versucht,
Dinge zu verstehen und zu manipulieren.
Die Gründe, warum er das tut, sind erstmal dahingestellt. Oft geht es wirklich
ums Interesse und es muss nicht unbedingt Strom durchfließen.
Okay, und William, was ist für dich ein Hacker oder eine Hackerin?
Ja, vielen Dank. Ich finde die beiden Definitionen hier ganz treffend,
weil ich Hacker nicht nur technisch, sondern auch theoretisch zu verstehen versuche.
Und theoretisch meine ich, ein Hacker hat immer etwas mit Geheimnissen zu tun.
Also was ist ein Geheimnis und wie kommt man in ein geschlossenes System?
Also ein Hacker muss eine sozusagen epistemologische Funktion haben,
dass man Informationen herausfinden möchte und dass man auch Systeme,
die mangelhaft sind oder die Fehler haben, verbessern möchte.
Da kommt noch die Verbesserungskomponente. Aber das ist, finde ich,
interessanterweise eine sehr viel engere Definition als bei den anderen beiden.
Du sagst also, HackerInnen sind grundsätzlich sozusagen Leute,
die in Systeme einbrechen oder ich formuliere es mal spitz, Systeme vorsätzlich
kaputt machen, um sie besser zu machen.
Aber eins von beiden ist für dich immer zwangsweise verbunden mit dem Hacken.
Ja, das kann schon sein. ja ich finde
interessant weil das war das schon so ein bisschen die spannweite aufzeigt also
an dem einen ende sozusagen sehr sehr klar und fokussiert also
auf technisch digitale geräte und ich nenne es jetzt mal zerstörung und im anderen
seite sagen im weitesten sinne ich fühle mich irgendjemand hat mal gesagt sozusagen
also dinge zu was benutzen für das sie eigentlich nicht gedacht sind also das
ist ja die weitestmögliche definition vom hacker genau Genau,
und ich würde auch sagen,
sie sind Problemlöser und deswegen gibt es auch Vorgänger von Hackern,
sogar bevor es Computer gegeben hat.
Sag mal ein Beispiel. Kannst du da ein konkretes Beispiel sagen?
Vielleicht, ich denke an Detektive oder vielleicht geht das zum Experiment.
Also Leute, die halt experimentieren.
Also schon noch so ein bisschen sagen, die Welt ergründen als Mindset vielleicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht, wo man jetzt, wenn man sagt typisch Hacker,
als erstes dran denkt, aber es steckt schon irgendwie so.
Der Wahrheit halber glaube ich noch was hinzufügen. Wir sind kein besonders
das repräsentative Sample für die Bevölkerung, weil wenn man
irgendjemand auf der Straße fragen würde, wer ein Hacker ist,
käme sofort ein krimineller Bezug und wir haben den jetzt hier oder zumindest
kaum erwähnt und das Hackerbild ist natürlich ambivalent, weil gerade durch
die Filme, über die wir ja noch irgendwie sprechen wollen und so.
Wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Ich weiß aber auch, es ist besser geworden, also wenn wir jetzt gerade noch
dabei sind, ich glaube durch so Sachen wie den ja sehr medienwirksamen Chaos-Kongress
in den letzten Jahren Ist der Hackerbegriff, hat er sich deutlich geändert?
Ich sage mal zum Positiven, das klingt jetzt so ein bisschen schmierig,
aber ich glaube, es ist ein anderer Hackerbegriff als früher.
Ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt so gar nicht so sicher, weil es gleichzeitig ja
mit Assange zum Beispiel und sozusagen weiter gibt es ja auch sozusagen das
medienwirksamste ist ja also schon irgendwie das,
ich sage jetzt mal das klassische Hacken, also etwas kaputt machen oder Geheimnisse
ans Tageslicht zerren, aber das für einen guten Zweck.
Also ich glaube schon, es gibt sozusagen eine positivere Wendung im Sinne von, also nochmal.
Ich glaube, was die Allgemeinheit sozusagen, also die Allgemeinheit von,
glaube ich, was Hacken ist, ist immer noch dasselbe, nämlich technische Systeme kaputt machen.
Was sich geändert hat, ist, das sind nicht nur Kriminelle, sondern die machen
das vielleicht auch für eine gute Sache.
Wie siehst du das, William, die Öffentlichkeit, also wenn du sozusagen den,
the man on the street, wenn du sozusagen, wenn man das ergründen wollen würde, was glaubst du, was...
Die Menschheit glaubt, was Hacker oder Hackerinnen sind. Ja,
also du hast auch diese Spalte zwischen,
fiktive Hacker und die Realität erwähnt und ich finde, das kommt auch in den
deutschen Filmen häufig vor im Vergleich zu amerikanischen Hackerfilmen.
Warte, warte, stopp. Ich will gleich zu den Hackern in den Filmen kommen.
Jetzt erst noch sozusagen was
glaubst du hat die Öffentlichkeit oder die Medienöffentlichkeit zu sagen?
Also was ist das Public Image von Hackern?
Oder hast du sozusagen jetzt gerade so geantwortet, wie du geantwortet hast,
weil du sagst, das wird so maßgeblich von der fiktiven Gestalt beeindruckt und
nicht von dem, was Hacker wirklich sind?
Das ist genau so gespalten. Also einige Leute stigmatisieren,
vielleicht dämonisieren Hacker und
glauben ja, diese Menschen haben keinen Beitrag zu einer besseren Welt.
Und andererseits, ich glaube, im Publikum gibt es immer noch ein größeres Bewusstsein
von Hackern, die sozusagen Hacktivist sind.
Also das Hacktivismus, das heißt, man versucht, die Welt zu verbessern.
Okay, sozusagen so könnte man es ganz grob und reißend machen.
Könnte sich auch zum Bild des Hackers in der Öffentlichkeit und was ist eigentlich
Hacken? Da kann man natürlich noch eine eigene Chaos-Radiosendung irgendwie
im 10er-Block zu machen.
Aber wir wollen ja heute eben über die fiktiven Hackerfiguren sprechen.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ich habe mich gefragt, wie fängt man am besten an?
Und ich glaube, meine erste Frage ist, man könnte jetzt natürlich sozusagen
filmgeschichtlich vielleicht irgendwie sehr zurückschauen und sagen,
irgendwie Metropolis, der Film aus den 20er Jahren, da wurde ein künstlicher
Mensch gebaut, das ist bestimmt auch irgendwie Hacking.
Aber wenn ihr jetzt zurückdenkt, vielleicht in eure persönliche Mediengeschichte,
wann habt ihr zum ersten Mal einen Hacker in einem Film gesehen und habt den
auch so als sozusagen sowas empfunden?
Ich denke, das war bei mir 23. Aber da hatte ich vorher schon eine Debatte drüber.
Also da hatte ich schon über den Film gesprochen, bevor ich den Film gesehen habe. Okay.
Also insofern zählt das nicht so richtig, muss ich sagen.
Was war das bei dir? Sag du mal, Kasper.
MacGyver. MacGyver kann ich natürlich eigentlich auch schon.
Kennst du auch noch MacGyver?
Oh Gott, jetzt kommt das Alter.
William, was war denn die erste Hacker-Figur im Film, an die du dich erinnern
kannst, für dich? Keanu Reeves.
Nicht nur Matrix, sondern auch Johnny Mnemonic.
Ah, okay, Johnny Mnemonic. Oh Gott, das ist ein Film, also Matrix würde ich
denken, kennt wahrscheinlich wirklich fast jede Hörerin.
MacGyver muss man vielleicht tatsächlich kurz erklären. MacGyver war kein digitaler
Hacker, sondern… Es war eine Serie, kein Kinofilm. War eine Serie und das war
ein Typ, der hat sozusagen, also das Meme ist, gib ihm einen Korgummi und eine
Büroklammer, der bastelte Bombe draus.
Der war halt immer in irgendwelche ganz krassen Dinge verwickelt und hat halt
immer irgendwas gebastelt.
Gehackt würde man heute sagen. Und das war dann sozusagen die Lösung des Problems.
Er hat auch tatsächlich gehackt. Er hat mit Computern manipuliert.
Und zwar selten. Die meisten hatten irgendwas anderes, wie Radius oder Cactus oder so.
Aber er hatte auch tatsächliche Computerhacks in seiner Serie.
Der war ziemlich populär. Ich weiß nicht, ob der nicht in den USA populär war.
Es gab doch einen Reboot auch. Das ist doch vor ein paar Jahren.
Gab es eine neue Makeover-Serie. Die aber dann schon wieder eingestellt ist wahrscheinlich.
Mit demselben Schauspieler? Nee, nee. Oh Gott.
Sein Name ist jetzt ein Begriff, also auch ein Verb, wenn man etwas MacGyver hat.
Ja, macht man auch im Deutschen. Ja klar, das sagt, ich habe das MacGyver.
Das heißt, dass man das irgendwie gehackt hat sozusagen. Also so zusammengebastelt.
Und dann aber vielleicht, William, kannst du auch kurz sagen, Johnny Manik.
Worum geht der Film nochmal? Das geht irgendwie um Datenkurieren. Ist eine Serie?
Ja, das heißt, man hackt das Gehirn. Ähnlich zu Matrix, aber auch anders.
Ein bisschen physikalischer als in Matrix zu sein.
Matrix war einfach ein Blockbuster. Ich glaube, es hatte kulturell mehr Impact, oder?
Aber das ist ja noch so religiös überformt und so. Über Matrix wurden bestimmt
auch sehr viele Bücher geschrieben worden.
Aber wir sehen, bei dir ist es also ein Jahrzehnt später.
Die Gnade der späten Geburt. So, aber dann jetzt mal sozusagen Butter bei die
Fische. Hacker in Filmen.
Ich glaube die Hauptfrage, die mich beschäftigt ist, sind Hacker in Filmen die
fiktive Abbildung des Realen oder sind das eigentlich so Geschichtsschablonen, die man braucht?
Was sind Hacker in Filmen? Es ist ganz anders in den USA als in Deutschland.
In den USA ist es meistens Science Fiction, also bisher.
Es gibt realistische Figuren, die auf echte Hacker basiert sind,
aber die meisten sind wie Keanu Reeves.
Also man trägt alles schwarz und Sonnenbrille und ist gar nicht in der Real World.
Im Vergleich sind alle deutschen Filme, die ich kenne, über Hacker ganz realistisch,
obwohl ein paar stark dramatisiert sind.
Okay, aber wäre das auch der entscheidende Unterschied, den du sehen würdest,
dass es in den deutschen Filmen vergleichsweise realitätsnah ist?
Wenn das auf eine echte Person basiert ist, dann versucht der Film teils wenigstens,
sich auf die Wahrheit zu beschränken und nicht zu viel extra zu haben.
Aber dann lass uns doch mal versuchen rauszufinden, ob die Figuren,
die da abgebildet werden, verschieden sind.
Weil was mich wirklich interessieren würde, ist, welche Rollen die Figur des Hackers im Film hat.
Also wenn man es jetzt ganz platt sieht, dann würde ich sagen, kennt man...
Also ich bin der Einzige, glaube ich, der hier sozusagen nicht irgendwie mehr
zu dem Thema gearbeitet hat.
Deswegen, wenn ich jetzt über Hacker im Film nachdenke, würde ich sagen,
es gibt den Hacker als Bösewicht, also will die Welt kaputt machen oder jemand
zugrunde richten oder was auch immer.
Es gibt den Hacker als irgendwie Erlöser, also der eine Mensch,
der das komplexe System durchsteigt und so irgendwie alles rettet.
Und dann gibt es noch den Hacker als Sidekick.
Das ist dann oft sozusagen jemand, der auch Barrieren überwindet,
aber dem Haupthelden sozusagen neben Gott ist. Also Die Hard 4 war das,
glaube ich, sozusagen, gibt es so ein paar Beispiele.
Also so der Hacker als Comic Relief, also eher so eine Art Zauberfigur oder so.
Das wären meine drei Schablonen, die ich auf Hackerfiguren in Filmen erleben würde.
Wie ist das bei euch? Kasper, du hast ja sozusagen diese, dich da lange mit
beschäftigt. Hast du auch so Archetypen von Hackerfiguren in Filmen aus, finde ich, gemacht?
Na, ich glaube, und das hat William auch in seinem Buch geschrieben,
dass zum Beispiel in den deutschen Filmen das gar nicht so sehr weiß oder schwarz ist, sondern oft grau.
Also das, es gibt ja auch die Whiteheads, Blackheads und Greyheads.
Und ich fand das sehr, sehr überzeugend dargestellt, dass in Filmen wie 23.
Who Am I, die Hacker so dazwischen sind.
Die sind nicht gut und die sind nicht böse sondern die
sind einfach wie sie sind sie sind oft politisch
manchmal aber auch nicht das fand ich sehr
gut ich habe jetzt im vorfeld zum podcast
heute noch mal darüber nachgedacht dass mir zumindest auffällt dass ich irgendwie
was verändert hat dass eine weile lang hacker vor allen dingen gegen maschinen
gekämpft haben also so kann ich sage ich mal die wild Und dann später auch Hacker
gegen Hacker gekämpft haben. Aber es war erst Man vs.
Machine und dann später Hacker vs.
Hacker. So, das hat sich, glaube ich, verschoben.
Aber du hast jetzt sozusagen eine Frage, die ich wahrscheinlich weiter hinten
stellen würde, jetzt schon beantwortet, aber die ursprüngliche Frage,
welche Archetypen an Hackerfiguren siehst du im Film?
Also der deutsche Hacker an sich ist sozusagen schon mal nicht so schwarz-weiß,
wie siehst du das im Rest der Hackerfilme? Okay, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
zwei, drei amerikanische Filme, die mir einfallen.
Wargames ist auch ein grauer Hacker, weil der will spielen und baut wirklich Mist.
Das ist für mich typisch grau.
Tron ist auch irgendwie grau, der will nichts richtig Gutes und so.
Also tatsache ist diese grau färbung ich
sehe die schon relativ oft es gibt dann in tron legacy gibt es
dann wirklich den evil hacker der dann
dagegen ist aber eigentlich sehe ich sehr viel grau tatsache als figuren also
der hacker immer als ambivalentes element genau ambivalentes passende worte
ok ich glaube den archetypen ich würde noch einen hinzufügen aber ich bin ja
nicht die Film-Hauschi, ja?
Aber du bist auch sozusagen Teil des Chaos-Radios und deswegen musst du jetzt
auch Fragen beantworten.
Ein Archetyp würde ich, also ich würde noch einen nehmen, der nicht so.
Der eigentlich mehr diese Social-Komponente bisschen, also was man heute Social
Engineering nennt, mit reinfügt.
Also so eine Hacker-Figur, der jetzt nicht unbedingt immer nur ein technisches
System bedient oder irgendwas kaputt macht, sondern der auch Manipulationstechniken
über Computer hinaus benutzt.
Den würde ich vielleicht noch dazu zunehmen, weil mir da so einige einfallen.
Aber wie gesagt, macht mal hier eure Archetypen unter euch aus.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch wesentlich weniger Hackerfilme gesehen als ihr. Also ich habe glaube ich,
Dann habe ich alle gesehen. Aber ich glaube, nicht so viele wie ihr.
Okay, na dann William, sag du nochmal. Am Bevelenz auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, es hat einen Punkt gegeben, irgendwann vielleicht in den 90ern.
Und das hat auch Steven Levy in seinem Buch erwähnt.
Kannst du kurz sagen, welches Buch? Das heißt auch Hackers as Heroes,
aber nicht im deutschen Welt.
Im Allgemeinen. Und Terlevi hat gesagt, ja, am Anfang waren Hacker nur Nerds oder Verlierer.
Ja, das Loser, als du Markus erwähnt hast.
Und dann ist es irgendwann passiert, dass man auch als cool dargestellt wird.
Und ja, Zauberer auch. Also das ist ganz zauberhaft, dass man von einem Nerd zu einem Rockstar geht.
Vielleicht auf einem Tag. Und ja, das ist vielleicht, weil Programmiersprache,
Programmieren etwas Mainstream geworden ist.
Und dadurch erkennt man im Publikum, okay, diese Leute, vielleicht 10Xer,
Hacker oder jemand, der sehr fähig im Hacken ist, sind ganz cool,
ja, wegen ihres Schattens.
Ich habe in der Vorbereitung der Sendung habe ich mir noch eine Frage gestellt,
nämlich die Frage, also der wir heute zusammengekommen sind und auch das Buch,
das du geschrieben hast, und auch die Sachen, die du Kasper irgendwie damals.
Aber da geht es ja immer sozusagen, das ist immer der Versuch der Ergründung,
also die Hacker sind dann schon menschliche Figuren.
Und ich habe mich gefragt, ob das schon immer so war oder ob das schon immer
stimmt, dass die Hacker wirklich als menschliche Figuren gedacht sind oder ob
FilmemacherInnen irgendwann dachten, so Mensch, irgendwie diese ganzen Sachen mit dem Computer,
da müssen wir was drüber erzählen, die Maschinen können wir aber nicht darstellen.
Deswegen nehmen wir die Menschen, die sie bedienen und fügen die im Film ein,
aber die gehören im eigentlichen Sinne gar nicht zum Ensemble.
Also ich habe mich gefragt, ob es, also jetzt irgendwie aktuell ist natürlich
mit diesem Hacker zum Rockstar werden und Neo und der Matrix,
da geht es schon auch um die Menschen, aber ob es in vielen anderen Filmen vielleicht
so war, dass Hacker genau genommen
gar nicht Teil des Schauspiels sozusagen, wenn man so will, waren.
Waren, also gar nicht Teil der Figuren waren, sondern eigentlich eher so eine
Art Plot-Device, also eigentlich eher Kulisse um das komplexe Ding Digitaltechnik im Film darzustellen.
Also Kasperl hast du vorhin die schöne Formulierung verwendet,
irgendwie wie werden Bildschirme auf Bildschirmen gezeigt und weil das nicht
geht, ob man dann sozusagen den Hacker als so eine Art Proxy für die Bildschirme
eigentlich genommen hat. Also ich hätte jetzt schon eine Antwort.
Ja bitte, das ist aber so eine Idee durch meinen Kopf, weil es ist auch Quatsch.
Die Idee klingt sehr valide, ich würde aber sagen nein, weil Weil,
um Beispiele anzubringen, es gibt ja sehr schöne filmische Beispiele,
in denen auch schon früh, wenn der Matron als Beispiel in den Computer reingefahren
wird und es werden Datenautobahnen gezeigt,
sehr, sehr beliebtes Motiv, die Datenautobahn im Computer.
Ich glaube, William hat in seinem Buch über den Wormhole-Effekt geschrieben.
Das kannst du ja noch mal erklären, weil ich kannte die Bezeichnung nicht, fand ich ganz toll.
Also es gab auf jeden Fall filmische Darstellungen, die nicht den Hacker als
Figur gebraucht hätten.
Ich glaube, dass der wirklich so gemeint war dann als Person. Okay. William?
Also ja, die Interesse an Hackern liegt auch an Anonymität.
Teils gedacht ist das kein Mensch, sondern etwas, das im Computer halt passiert.
Aber das ist auch die Supermacht eines Hackers.
Nämlich sagt Benjamin im Film Who Am I, dass seine Supermacht die Unsichtbarkeit ist.
Er sagt, ich bin unsichtbar. Und das hat mich so an diese Figuren gezogen und
hat mein Interesse auch gesteigt.
Aber sag mal zu dem, Kasper hat eben diesen Begriff, den du auch benutzt hast,
mit dem Warmhole in dem Buch nochmal angesprochen.
Erklär mal, was damit gemeint ist und welche typischen Beispiele dir da einfallen?
So wenn man viele Farben und Lichter im Fernsehen oder auf dem Schirm sieht,
als ob man durch den Raum fliegt.
So versucht man, das Erlebnis eines Hackers darzustellen, sodass ganz normale
Menschen, die nicht programmieren können, irgendwie vorstellen können,
wie ist das, so viel Verständnis und so viel Können zu haben im Computer.
Also quasi die Magie und Immersion irgendwie zu visualisieren.
Ich glaube, wir müssen sozusagen an der Stelle kurz mal die Bremse anziehen
und Quietsch machen, weil hier drei Filmnamen fallen und immer häufiger fallen werden,
was einfach damit zu tun hat, dass das auch ganz prominente Beispiele in Williams Buch sind. sind.
Und ich bin ja der Moderator, deswegen kann ich mich schön raussetzen.
Das sind drei Beispiele.
Das heißt, jeder von euch kann jetzt einen Film mal bitte ganz kurz beschreiben.
Und ich würde wieder mit Konstanze den Anfang machen, weil du hast es vorhin
erwähnt, dass 23 sozusagen dein erstes Hacker-Filmerlebnis letztlich war.
Kannst du kurz den geneigten HörerInnen, die nicht wissen, worum es mit diesem
Film geht, kurz den Film beschreiben?
Also als erstes müsste man glaube ich wissen, dass der Film schon mehrere Jahrzehnte alt ist.
Also dass natürlich die heutige Computertechnik und dass jeder ein Zuhause hat
noch nicht unbedingt Teil dieses Plotschens, denn da wird zu sagen, jemand porträtiert,
der in ein Computersystem einbricht und dabei dann auch erwischt wird und es
endet sozusagen, wenn ich die
Story jetzt mal ganz zusammengefasst darstellen will, das Ende tödlich.
Spoiler. Aber das Interessante an 23 ist einmal, wie die Hacks an sich tatsächlich
dargestellt werden und natürlich auch, das wird eine Vorlage.
Das ist nicht ganz klar geworden, das ist nach einer wahren Geschichte.
Genau, es ist nämlich eine Vorlage in der Realität.
Das heißt natürlich noch lange nicht, dass alle Personen total realistisch dargestellt
werden, dafür gibt es natürlich künstlerische Freiheit, aber dennoch ist es
eine Geschichte, die so ähnlich stattgefunden hat.
Kannst du die ganz kurz erzählen? Was?
Dahinter ist ja sozusagen das Schlagwort des KGB-Hack. Ja, also das Interessante
daran, dass da auch noch quasi eine Spionagegeschichte mit drin ist,
denn der Einbruch in die fremden Computernetze hat auch noch sozusagen eine
Geheimdienstwelt, die sich nach sich zieht.
Der KGB ist nämlich der Geheimdienst der damaligen Sowjetunion und der hat sich sozusagen,
der Hacker hat sich eingelassen mit ausländischen Spionen und ist sicherlich
auch sozusagen dann, ja, gerät sozusagen in Kreise.
Er auch nicht mehr überschaut und er hat dann als erwischt wird auch sehr stark
zu tun mit dem deutschen geheimdienst denn die sind in dem film sozusagen noch
dargestellt insbesondere als verhörende war auch manipulierende,
Ich bin nicht gut in so einem, habe ich jetzt zusammengefasst, die gucken mich alle an.
Ich würde einen Detail vielleicht noch hinzufügen wollen und das ist,
dass der Film erzählt hat die Geschichte von Karl Koch,
also nach einer wahren Begegnung dieses KGB-Hacks und der Film rahmt das Ganze
in einer Besessenheit der Hauptfigur für die Zahl 23 und die Illuminatus-Reihe, also die,
man würde heute sagen Verschwörungserzählung, die in Buchform mehr aufgriff
und dann sozusagen selber in diese Vorstellung hinein gleitet.
Und das ist, also vielleicht wird das auch so ein wiedererkennendes Element,
dass Hacker sozusagen immer auch so ein bisschen anfällig sind,
also Hacker in Filmen immer so ein bisschen anfällig sind so für dieses ist
die Welt nicht vielleicht doch ganz anders?
Ja, der wird auch sehr reingezogen in seine eigene Geschichte.
Also ja, also ja. Ich bin nicht so gut in Film-Macher-Zählen.
Oh, ich komme jetzt vor zu Begüntalotter-Filmen. Aber können wir sagen, es ist ein guter Film?
Ich finde ihn natürlich insofern gut, als dass der Hacker nicht,
also und die Tätigkeit des Hackens,
nicht so überzeichnet sind, wie man es eben in vielen Filmen hat und es ist
auch kein Überheld oder so, sondern der wird als absolut menschliche Person dargestellt.
Er hat auch einfach eine Geschichte, die aus ihm spricht.
Ja, er ist auch nicht irgendwie platt oder er ist jedenfalls vielschichtig und.
Es ist aber auch so, dass ich von den Menschen, die damals die Filmemacher beraten haben,
Von denen kenne ich welche, die gehören zum Chaos Computer Club.
Man hat damals seitens der Filmemacher versucht, möglichst realistisch an so
einen Haken ranzugehen und das ist aus meiner Sicht auch gelungen.
Kaspar, welchen Film möchtest du? Es gibt ja noch jetzt Who Am I und es gibt
noch The Billion Dollar Code. Dann nehme ich Who Am I.
Ich sage kurz, ich spoile jetzt vielleicht etwas.
Deswegen, wenn man noch nicht geguckt hat, kurz pausieren und ihn schauen.
Ich würde ihn auf jeden Fall, wenn man sich mit Hacker in Filmen auseinandersetzen
will, als Sehempfehlung aussprechen.
Der ist dafür auf jeden Fall gut, also um die Filmgeschichte sich anzuschauen.
Der Film beginnt damit, dass Benjamin, ein junger Typ, sich der Polizei stellt
und anfängt ein großes Geständnis abzulegen und nur grob umrissen.
Es geht darum, dass der BND gehackt wurde und es entspinnt sich eine wahnwitzige
Geschichte, die ein Krieg von Hackergruppen untereinander ist.
Das ist so jetzt mal ganz grob zusammengefasst.
Das Wichtige ist, es ist eine Netflix-Produktion von 2015, 14 oder so.
War eine Netflix-Produktion, glaube ich. Oh, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Das ist schon eine Weile her auf jeden Fall.
Nee, ich glaube, das war vor Netflix-Zeiten, oder? Okay, dann vielleicht habe
ich mich jetzt geirrt. Auf jeden Fall 2014, also nicht sehr,
sehr alt, aber auch schon zehn Jahre alt.
Er nimmt Bezüge wirklich. Also Hauptdarsteller ist Tom Schilling,
also deutsche Produktion.
Ja, er nimmt Bezüge auch zum Beispiel auf den Chaos Computer Club,
wörtlich. Da gibt es so eine Szene, wo er sagt, ja, das erinnert mich an frühe
Zeiten, Chaos Computer Club und so.
Das ist sehr, sehr lustig.
Und es gibt in dem Film filmisch eine Sache, die ich sehr, sehr besonders fand,
weil ich mich ja immer wieder dafür interessiere, wie man Hacken darstellt.
Und oft ist es ja so, dass man ein bisschen peinlich berührt,
wenn man davon Ahnung hat, vom Fernseher sitzt und denkt, oh Gott.
Und der macht eine Sache, finde ich gut, weil die sehr mutig ist und zwar versuchen
die das Darknet darzustellen.
Also diesen anonymen Platz im Internet, wie stellt man das dar?
Und das machen die als Szenen in einer U-Bahn,
wo Menschen Masken aufhaben und das ist so psychodelisch überzeichnet und das
hat natürlich überhaupt nichts damit zu tun, wie das Darknet aussieht,
aber ein Film ist ja Kunst und da tritt der Film wirklich als Kunst und der vermittelt ein Gefühl,
finde ich, beim Angucken, wo ich sage, da kann ich mitgehen.
Also Tatsache finde ich, als Film funktioniert es für mich so,
das Darknet darzustellen.
Genau, deswegen fand ich den besonders in der Liste, der hat,
es gibt auch viel Kritik an dem Film, die ich jetzt äußern könnte,
aber die Darknet-Darstellung war mal was Innovatives das hat mir gefallen.
Das fand ich auch interessant, weil das sozusagen so an der Hälfte war zwischen,
wir machen es so verschwommen, dass man da rein interpretieren kann aber nicht
so konkret, dass man es irgendwie genau, wir kommen gleich dazu,
warum Constanze lacht, aber dazu später mehr, fehlt noch Billion-Dollar-Code.
William, kannst du kurz Billion-Dollar-Code nacherzählen?
Ja, kann ich, aber nicht ohne zuerst zurück auf diese zwei Filme zu gehen.
Also, Who Am I mit den Masken ist das eigentlich eine Erwähnung an eine ganze
Geschichte von Widerstand.
Zum Beispiel die Maske von Guy Fawkes.
Also, was diese Gruppe und dieser Benjamin machen und macht,
ist Widerstand gegen Unrecht.
Und ich finde das ganz wichtig in diesem Film.
23 ist etwas anders. Ich finde dieses Widerstandselement nicht das Größte, aber es ist da.
Und Karl Koch ist eigentlich 1989 gestorben.
Und der Film kommt nicht bis 1998, also zehn Jahre, bevor dieser Film gemacht wird.
Und die Umstände seines Todes sind auch ganz fragwürdig. Und viele Leute im
Chaos Computer Club stellen immer noch Fragen darüber.
Aber auch ein Element im Film 23 war, dass Karl Koch sich verantwortlich gesehen
hat zum Chernobyl, weil er in diesem System ein bisschen gehackt hat,
aber nichts gemacht hat.
So, jetzt zum Billion Dollar Code. Das ist ein Film, wo die Gründer von einer
Firma in Deutschland, Artencom, die auch Teilnehmer an Chaos Computer Club waren.
Und diese Serie, das ist eine Serie im Netflix, ist eigentlich über die Beziehung
zwischen amerikanischen Hackern und Firmen und den Deutschen.
Und diese Leute gehen in der Serie nach Kalifornien.
Sie treffen man, sie treffen sich an Google und sind ganz gespannt.
Aber dann, was Google mit ihnen macht, das kommt zum Skandal.
Also es geht ein bisschen um die Geschichte, dass die Leute von Art und Com
ein Programm gemacht haben, Terravision heißt das und Google, Google Earth.
Und dann ist die Serie, die Geschichte des Prozesses zwischen Art und Com,
die halt sagen, Google hat mit Google Earth Code von uns geklaut.
Und das sozusagen, genau, da geht es um diesen Prozess.
Kaspar, du sagst gerade, als hättest du noch eine Anmerkung?
Nö, also ich finde bei der Billion-Dollar-Code-Geschichte einfach gut zu wissen,
dass die Firma Art & Com einfach gibt.
Also das ist eine aktive Firma, deswegen fand ich das sehr besonders,
so etwas Dokumentarisches über lebende Entitäten wie Google und Art & Com zu
sehen. Das ist schon sehr spannend.
Und die Menschen gibt es ja. Ich wollte gerade fragen, es gibt ja zwei Hauptcharaktere,
nämlich Juri Müller und den anderen Namen leider vergessen. also diese beiden
Hauptcharaktere, sind die auch.
Der eine ist ganz klar Pavel, der ist deutlich zu erkennen. Die haben die Namen geändert.
Also andere Namen, aber sozusagen, das sind schon, die Referenzen sind klar.
Das ist nicht sozusagen, da sind mehrere Personen in einer zusammengekapselt,
sondern diese beiden Charaktere, die haben auch sozusagen tatsächlich Realweltentsprechung in einer Person.
Und die haben sich auch dazu geäußert, ne? Also die sind, die haben sich selber
nach Erscheinen geäußert dazu.
Ja, jetzt, William, ist meine erste Frage, die konkret mit dir und deiner Forschung
selber in dem Buch zu tun hat. Das sind ja alles drei Filme,
die, also bei Who Am I ist es sozusagen, ist das sehr weit weg.
Ja, also da gibt es sozusagen Anspielungen auf die realen, auf reale Hacker,
aufs reale Hackertum kann man so sagen. Aber es gibt eben diese Verknüpfung zur echten Welt.
Es ist halt, also natürlich hat auch eine Neo und Matrix was mit unserer Welt
zu tun, weil es sozusagen Geschichten und Geschichten von Veränderungen und
so weiter erzählt, aber es hat halt keine sehr offensichtliche Realweltentsprechung.
Sind das jetzt sozusagen zufällig drei Beispiele für deutsches Bewegtbild mit
HackerInnen, die auch Realbezug haben?
Oder ist das schon etwas, was du als Unterschied festmachst zwischen Hacker
in deutschen Filmen und Hacker anderswo, dass es immer diesen Bedarf an Authentizität
gibt oder dass immer sozusagen eine echte Geschichte dahinter steckt?
Ich finde schon. Also in Deutschland gibt es eine ganz andere Beziehung im Großen
und Ganzen zu Science Fiction.
Ja, Sci-Fi-Filme gibt es nicht
so oft in Deutschland, weil man etwas realistischer möchte vielleicht.
Und das hat auch mit der deutschen Geschichte zu tun.
Und ja, Billion Dollar Code zum Beispiel.
Ich erinnere mich daran, als ich das erste Mal Google Earth benutzt habe,
war das ungefähr 2005. Und ich musste ein Programm herunterladen im Computer
und das war nicht perfekt.
Es war ganz langsam zum Laden und es hatte Fehler.
Und ich glaube, niemand hat gewusst, dass es Television zuerst gegeben hat.
Und ja, die Realität von den deutschen Hackerfilmen ist ganz wunderbar, meine ich.
Also etwas einzigartig zu der deutschen Filmindustrie.
Kannst du das ein bisschen weiter ausführen, was du damit meinst? Ja, versuche ich.
Es gibt nicht so viel Sci-Fi in den letzten 70 Jahren von deutschen Filmen.
Jetzt gibt es ein paar, zum Beispiel Paradise ist ein deutscher Film mit Science
Fiction und man macht was mit Genetik in der Zukunft.
Und ich glaube, das kommt jetzt erst, weil es schon tabu war.
Und genau weil es tabu gewesen ist, ist jetzt Science Fiction etwas häufiger in deutschen Filmen.
Also weil diese Filme so fiktiv sind, Science Fiction meine ich,
gab es noch Platz, um deutsche Hacker als Helden darzustellen.
Also es gab einen Platz, sagen wir, in der diagetischen Welt von Filmen.
Was ist eine diagetische Welt von Filmen? Da muss ich kurz nachfragen.
Das ist mir ein Fachbegriff, den ich bekannt habe. Das ist die erzählte Welt
in allen Romanen, Kurzgeschichten, aller Art Geschichten, die gedreht werden
oder geschrieben werden.
Das ist niemals die Wirklichkeit selbst, aber das ist eine Vorstellung von dem Autor.
Und deutsche Hacker haben etwas in der Erfahrung, was amerikanische Hacker nicht haben.
Also meinetwegen ist das politikverbunden. Politik, Aktivismus und vielleicht Betrieb sogar.
Ich denke auch, dass diese politische Komponente ist ja bei den Beispielen auch
relativ stark. Das wäre eine Frage, die ich für Konstanze und für euch hätte.
Nämlich, wie oft ist es, dass man sich mit Politik verbunden fühlt oder dass
man versucht, etwas politisch oder im Kommerz zu schaffen?
Meinst du jetzt im Film oder meinst du jetzt sozusagen Konstanze und Kaspar?
Ja, ich meine, Konstanze und Kaspar.
Wenn ich das recht verstehe, meinst du, du beziehst dich jetzt auf die Realität
und nicht auf die Realität im Film, oder?
Beides. Also man spürt das im Film, dass es eine lange Geschichte ist,
dass deutsche Hacker eine, vielleicht wenn ich nicht irre, eine Beziehung zu
der damaligen KDP gegen Nazis hat.
Und dass die Geschichte so immer weitergeht, dass man vielleicht gegen Faschismus kämpft.
Darf ich versuchen sozusagen die Frage umzuformulieren, um zu verstehen,
ob ich sie richtig verstanden habe, ist die Frage, die du stellst im Prinzip,
sind Hacker in Deutschland und sind Hacker in deutschen Filmen meistens politisch
motiviert, meistens als Widerstand oder Bekämpfung des Faschismus vielleicht
sozusagen in einer sehr weit gegriffenen Form.
Also es gibt auch in Who Am I, das ist im Prinzip ein Actionfilm.
Wenn man es ganz kurz beschreiben möchte, ist es eine Mischung aus Usual Suspects und einem Actionfilm.
Da gibt es halt auch eine wichtige, also die gehört zur Dramaturgie schon relevant
dazu, wo die halt einfach eine Nazi-Veranstaltung crashen.
Und das ist deren Kern, das zu machen.
Genau. Ich kann zwei Beispiele aus den Filmen erwähnen.
Im Film 23 sagt Karl Koch seinem Vater, wir kämpfen gegen den Mist,
den deine Generation gebaut hat.
Und er meint, ja, wir demonstrieren gegen AKWs. Und ja, dann ist meine Frage,
trifft das euch besonders im Herzen?
Und musste man damals oder noch heute etwa gegen generationelle Zusammenbrüche
oder Fehler einer älteren Generation kämpfen durch das Hacken?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eine schwierige Frage, weil ja eigentlich sozusagen
diese ganze Hacker-Szene in Deutschland in der Zeit entstanden ist,
wo dieser ganze, der Kulturkampf,
der sich vor allen Dingen an den Universitäten abspielte, wo diese ganze Generation,
die noch aus Nazitraditionen oder noch selber Mitglied der NSDAP waren und so,
ganz aktiv kritisiert wurden.
Eigentlich ist ja erst eine zusammengewachsene Hacker-Szene erst nach der deutschen
Wiedervereinigung entstanden.
Das heißt, ich würde sagen, dass diese Widerstandskomponente,
wenn sie gemeint ist als Widerstand,
der sich vor allen Dingen gegen Rechte oder auf jeden Fall irgendwie Unberechtigte
oder so unmenschliche Teile, da würde ich es nicht unbedingt so stark drauf beziehen, weil ich.
Ja, dafür ist vielleicht dann auch der Zeitpunkt, wo die Hackerszene,
die tatsächliche Hackerszene in Deutschland größer wurde, ziemlich spät.
Und da waren, glaube ich, diese ganzen Kämpfe, die ausgetragen wurden,
die vor allen Dingen aber im Westen Deutschlands ausgetragen wurden,
die waren eigentlich schon wieder abgeebbt, würde ich sagen.
Denn wenn man jetzt so in die Zeit, die 90er oder ab 1995 oder so guckt,
da waren ja dann die Grünen im Bundestag.
Also da war ja schon eine gewisse Zeitenwende einfach schon passiert.
Also ich würde das nicht so direkt drauf beziehen. Trotzdem glaube ich,
dass das Widerständische eine große Komponente ist.
Die findet sich in der Hackerethik, die findet sich auch in wirklich wirklich
sehr, sehr vielen politischen Aktionen, die sich auch nicht nur in Deutschland,
aber besonders in Deutschland mit der Hacker-Szene verbinden.
Das Widerständische scheint mir schon wichtig. Und bei Who Am I sieht man das,
finde ich, auch ganz krass an der Werbung, die damals gemacht hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch erinnert, hier in Deutschland war diese Maske,
die ganz doll an diese Guy-Maske erinnerte, also optisch.
Damit wurde beworben. Also es war total klar, dass diese Widerständische im Mittelpunkt steht.
Und weswegen ich vorhin so lachen musste, war also bei Who Am I?
Ich hatte das schon neulich mal erzählt.
Zu damaligen Zeiten kamen ganz viele Filmemacher oder Fernsehserienmacher zum
TCC und haben sich beraten lassen.
Haben gesagt, ey, wir wollen diesen oder jenen Film haben, könnt ihr vielleicht
mal unser Screenplay lesen? Könnt ihr mal sagen, ist das irgendwie albern?
Und die auch, also die von Who Am I? Die haben wir tatsächlich auch beraten.
Und wir haben immer diese Tubes und die Darstellung des Darknets krass gestritten.
Denn damals war der Begriff Darknet überhaupt nicht so bekannt.
Heute würden glaube ich, also würden viele damit irgendwas anfangen können und
Facebook ist mittlerweile im Darknet.
Aber damals war das noch so eine sehr... Entschuldigung, jetzt hast du es gesagt,
jetzt musst du auch erklären, was ist das Darknet und wieso gibt es seinen Facebook?
Okay. Als Darknet wird üblicherweise der Teil des Netzes bezeichnet,
der nicht ohne weiteres verfügbar ist oder man bestimmte Techniken benutzen muss,
um ihn zu erreichen und wo große Teile der Nutzerschaft anonymisiert agieren
können. So würde ich es jetzt mal definieren.
Und damals war das wirklich, also ich glaube, das weitverbreitete Bild vom Darknet
war, da kauft man irgendwie Drogen und klickt sich auf, Hacks, Mörder oder so.
Und insofern, ich fand die Darstellung mutig. Die hatten das schon in ihrem
Screenplay in der ersten Form, also bevor sie angefangen hatten,
den zu besetzen und Leute zu finden. und wir waren da nicht sehr begeistert
von. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Weil wir ja nicht künstlerisch gedacht haben. Du springst jetzt zum nächsten Thema.
Ich möchte tatsächlich noch mal ein bisschen genauer über die Darstellung von
Hacking, Vorgänger und Film, aber der Zusammenhang zwischen.
Politischem Aktivismus, Widerstand und Hackertum in der echten Welt,
in der Hosenwelt und in Filmen. Kasper?
Hast du Hosenwelt gerade gesagt? Ich habe Hosenwelt gesagt.
Darf ich auch wissen, was Hosenwelt ist? Naja, also ich finde,
es ist ja sozusagen mittlerweile ein bisschen albern davon zu reden,
wenn man vom Nicht-Digitalen redet, davon dann zu sagen echte Welt,
weil das Digitale ist auch unsere echte Welt mittlerweile.
Und in der Pandemie hat sich der Begriff Hosenwelt geprägt, weil man ja immer
im Videocall war und da war man immer nur von oben zu sehen.
Das heißt, wenn man virtuell war, musste man keine Hosen tragen.
Wenn man sich aber in der echten Welt begegnet, dann musste man Hosen oder Beinkleidung anhaben.
Und deswegen ist Hosenwelt sozusagen, finde ich, auch ein schönes Wort dafür
zu sagen, das ist eine nicht digitalisierte, physikalisch erlebbare Welt.
Ich werde keinen Kommentar, irgendeine Art zu Rosenwelt anbringen.
Falls ich jetzt auf die falsche Frage antworte, hängen wir nur damit zusammen.
Um das nochmal zu wiederholen, es geht um den, gibt es einen inhärenten Zusammenhang
zwischen politischem Aktivismus oder Widerstand gegen den Faschismus und Hackertum?
Ich glaube, es gibt, wir reden jetzt ja über Deutschland und deutsche Filme.
Ich glaube, es gibt in Deutschland einfach zwei Arten von Filmen.
Es gibt Filme, die sehr stark auf diese politische Komponente setzen oder da
auch in der Tradition stehen.
Mir ist auch jetzt im Vorfeld nochmal eingefallen, na klar, wir haben ja auch
wirklich die RAF-Geschichte in Deutschland, Filme wie Bader-Meinhof-Komplex
und so. Also da wäre es wahrscheinlich spannend, auch solche Filme mal zu kontrastieren.
Ich habe jetzt nicht dein ganzes Buch tief gelesen, vielleicht machst du das auch schon.
Ich glaube, es gibt aber auch Filme, die auch wie die deutsche Hacker-Szene eher unpolitisch sind.
Das merkt man auch auf so Kongressen wie dem Chaos-Kongress oder auch im Netz
gibt es so Sphären, wo drüber gestritten wird, will man hier Politik haben oder nicht.
Und es gibt auch eine sehr starke, wir wollen hier keinerlei politische Diskussion,
wir wollen einfach nur hacken.
Und ich, also mir fallen auch Hackerfilme ein in Deutschland,
die auch sehr früh sind, die schon in den 80er Jahren ein eher unpolitisches
Hacken machen. Ja, also das gibt es eben auch.
Deswegen würde ich das bejahen und auf jeden Fall anders als in Amerika sehen.
Das ist mir jetzt auch durch das aktuelle Thema nochmal aufgefallen.
Aber es gibt auch das unpolitische Hacken in Deutschland auf jeden Fall.
Ich würde fast noch eine Frage nachschieben wollen,
und zwar auch wieder an euch alle drei jetzt, aber nämlich die Frage,
ist dieser Zusammenhang, also jetzt vielleicht nicht des ursächlich politischen,
aber dieses widerständischen beim Hacker im Film vor allem deswegen da,
weil sich so besser Geschichten erzählen lassen?
Also vielleicht gibt es nicht sozusagen vielleicht in der Hosenwelt viel mehr
sozusagen Hacker und Hackerinnen,
die einfach sozusagen gerne irgendwie hacken aus Spaß und Freude und weder politisch
noch widerständisch sind,
aber halt wenn man im Film eine Geschichte erzählen will, dann muss die ja immer
meistens gegen was gehen und dann erzählt es sich halt einfacher,
wenn du halt eine Figur hast,
die was bekämpft oder etwas erreichen will oder so.
Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen in der Hacker-DNA. Am Ende musst du auch gegen
jemanden kämpfen, du bist am Rad ran,
schon die frühen Hacker müssen sich irgendwie Zugang zu Systemen irgendwie besorgen
und dann gibt es diese ganze Fraktion Knowledge Brings Fear,
also diese Hacker, die viel wissen, die müssen eben auch damit umgehen,
mit der Verantwortung, die damit kommt und so.
Also da, Fiedel ist, glaube ich, in dieser ganzen Hackergeschichte schon drin.
Also auch jenseits jetzt der Filmwelt.
Und dann natürlich, glaube ich, jetzt hat es sogar noch zugenommen,
Computer haben heute eine andere Bedeutung.
Die sind in alle Lebensbereiche hineingeschlichen und so. Deshalb denke ich
mal, dass es politisch schon zugenommen hat.
Aber wahrscheinlich würde man im Film auch immer Gegenbeispiele finden.
Aber was sie nicht falsch macht, es gibt es auch, es ist ein Nebeneinander.
Tja, meinetwegen doch. Also Constanza hat an die Hackerethik angedeutet und das finde ich ganz punk.
Also Hackerethik ist teils Datenschutz und teils Informationsfreiheit und das wird sofort politisch.
Und meinetwegen hat das doch mit den 68ern zu tun und diesen Generationsproblemen,
die an das deutsche Universitätssystem kommen.
Und das merkt man bei 23, dass wir dann anders im Film Who Am I?
In Who Am I, als diese Figuren diese Eulenspiegelei gegen eine faschistische
Partei machen, muss man fragen, inwiefern ist das realistisch?
Hat der Chaos Computer Club gegen ähnliche Gruppen gehackt in der Vergangenheit?
Das könnte doch gefährlich sein, oder?
Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist halt auch die damalige Zeit. Der Film ist halt auch zehn Jahre alt.
Und ich kann mich sehr gut erinnern, das ist ziemlich parallel dazu bei den
damaligen Kongressen, die natürlich nur ein Viertel so groß waren wie heute,
also der Chaos Communication Kongress, wird immer noch so richtig Fame-Seiten,
welche irgendwie NPD-Seiten, was damals die populärste rechte Partei war,
wieder mal defaced wurden und so.
Da gab es ja diese Szene. Defaced heißt, jemand bricht eine Webseite an und
spielt dann sozusagen eine eigene Grafik meistens auf. Genau.
Oder welche Datenbanken von irgendwelchen rechten T-Shirt-Shops erbeutet wurden.
Das war eine Zeit lang sehr populär. Und ich glaube, der TTT ist explizit links,
wenn man das auf der politischen Skala sehen wollte.
Was da auch, glaube ich, mit der Zunahme von dem Einfluss der rechten Parteien
hier in Deutschland, glaube ich, auch sehr viel deutlicher nach außen hin macht.
Also vor allen Dingen auf den Kongressen.
Aber zumindest aus der Geschichte, wie ich sie kenne, ich bin seit ungefähr,
oh Gott, ich glaube jetzt schon bald 20 Jahre oder so im CCC.
War das schon immer so? Also ich habe nie einen CCC erlebt, der nicht politisch war.
Aber wir haben, wenn es jetzt an die Filme geht, meistens auch immer die Filmemacher
beraten, wenn die zu uns kamen, meistens in sehr frühen Phasen,
die auch diese Komponente drin haben wollten.
Die anderen, die so einen klassischen CSI-Hacker, die irgendwie schon immer
drei Minuten hacken und dann sind sie drin, die kommen ja nicht zum CCC und fragen,
ob das eine sinnvolle Idee ist oder so, sondern die, die machen ihre komischen
… Aber könnte man hier auch sozusagen so, also beim Hacker im Film,
jetzt nicht nur auf Deutschland bezogen, auch so ein Triptychon aufmachen?
Es gibt sozusagen den guten Hacker und der gute Hacker ist meistens auch links.
Es gibt den bösen Weltzerstörung, ich mache euch alle kaputt Hacker.
Und es gibt sozusagen den Hacker als neutrales Werkzeug für die Detektivgeschichte
oder CSI oder was du gerade, kann man das so, Kasper hast du da?
Ich würde ja weiterhin nicht den guten Hacker so richtig sehen im Film,
aber den linken... Es gibt im Rollenspiel, gibt es chaotisch neutral oder so.
Chaotisch gut. Chaotisch gut. Genau, es gibt chaotisch gut, glaube ich,
im Rollenspiel Dungeons & Dragons.
Den sehe ich eher und der ist eher der linke Hacker. Da würde ich dann mitgehen.
Also für alle Nicht-Rollenspieler chaotisch gut, meist wildes Gute in der Welt.
Ihm ist aber das Gesetz relativ egal.
Und er macht sozusagen eher eher das, was er selbst als gut hält,
als sozusagen sich mit juristischen oder auch philosophischen Diskussionen oder
Reflexionen auseinanderzusetzen.
Ja, also mittlerweile gibt es dann immer ein Risiko, das man annehmen muss,
wenn man so einen Hack macht.
Und dann kommt die Frage, ist das, was legal ist, das Richtige oder muss man
etwas Illegales machen, um das Richtige zu schaffen?
Aber Hacker in Filmen müssen doch immer was Illegales machen, oder?
Das ist doch Teil ihrer Geschichte, des Hackers in Filmen ist doch,
dass er immer Illegales macht.
Und man muss spaß dabei
haben ist es bei
der filmfigur so kasper schüttelt
den kopf nein also erstmal muss ja nichts illegales machen wenn man zum beispiel
mac guy war als hacker definiert der ja nicht nicht immer unbedingt illegal
handelt ich weiß in der ersten folge mac guy war verschließt er schwefelsäure
tanken in der tafel schokolade das ist seine sein hack würde Ich würde aber sagen,
dass MacGyver jetzt eher die Kategorie Ausnahme bestätigt, die Regel ist, oder?
Ja, wir reden ja über Filme. Ja, eben, genau.
Im Grundsatz würde ich schon sagen, dass es eigentlich stimmt.
Oder meistens ist irgendwo mehr oder weniger eine Komponente,
wo man Grenzen übertritt, wo man auch weiß, das hätte man vielleicht legal nicht tun dürfen.
MARKUS TRANTOW Ja, aber Tron, da hackt, also oft sind es auch,
also es gibt ja oft Evil Corporations, die auch die Gesetze oder die Regeln
aufstellen, die gesetzeswidrig sind.
Also wenn wir uns darauf einigen, es geht nicht um Gesetze, sondern es geht
um Regelverstöße, wer auch immer die aufgestellt hat, dann bin ich dabei.
MARKUS TRANTOW Okay, der Regelverstoß als inneres Merkmal des Hackens.
Also, dazu kommt auch eine graue Zone, nicht nur von Ethik, sondern von Legalität.
Also im Billion Dollar Code machen sie etwas mit Daten von NASA,
das etwas fragwürdig ist.
Ob das illegal ist, sagen sie, nein. Ja, genau.
Und ich finde, hier ist übrigens ein realweltlicher Bezug, ganz ohne Frage.
Das ist ja tatsächlich bei Hackern bis heute und war auch schon früher immer
Teil des Denkens und Debattierens.
Also wo sind die Regeln, welche kann ich davon übertreten, welche sind ethisch
vielleicht zu rechtfertigen, obwohl sie legalistisch vielleicht nicht zu rechtfertigen
sind und was ist mit diesen von Kasper eben angesprochenen Evil-Entitäten.
Heute würde man sagen fette Tech-Konzerne, die sozusagen durch Oligopole oder
Monopole bestimmte Regeln setzen. Die waren auch schon immer da in der Geschichte
der CCC, aber auch in anderen Hacker-Szenen, also dass man gegen die kämpfen muss.
Und das spiegelt sich, finde ich, in vielen Filmen.
Und ja, jetzt bei The Billion Dollar Code ist es halt eher diese gerichtliche,
aber im Hintergrund ist der Konflikt ja auch zu sehen.
Ich finde auch in Billion Dollar Code, also für mich, müsst ihr sagen,
ob das stimmt, finde ich so ein bisschen eine Ausnahme, weil das Hacken sozusagen
dann ein Business Case auch ist.
Also im Prinzip ist hier das Hacken sozusagen, das ist nur die Hintergrundgeschichte
für das eigentliche Ding.
Also so kam es mir zumindest vor. Und die Frage ist, ist sozusagen das,
was Billion-Dollar-Quota macht, eine Ausnahme, wenn man über Hacker-Filme redet?
Sind Hacker eher sozusagen sonst so diese Hands-on-Dinger und nicht sozusagen
Teil einer großen Institution oder Business-Serie?
Ja, Kasper. William hat in seinem Buch auch sehr schön mit aufgeführt,
How to Sell Drugs Online Fast als Hackerfilm im weiteren Sinne oder Hackerserie.
Da geht es ja eigentlich in Anführungsstrichen nur darum, dass Drogen verkauft
werden, über das Dark Web glaube ich auch am Anfang.
Und da geht es ja auch um Business Case und zwar auch auf einer realen Vorlage.
Also das passt vielleicht dazu, dass wir es jetzt nicht nur im Billion-Dollar-Code
haben, sondern einen sehr, sehr ähnlichen Fall.
Also irgendwie stehen die, finde ich, im Zusammenhang, die beiden Serien,
weil beides Mal geht es um einen Business Case, der aus so einem Hacker-Gedanken irgendwie kommt.
Diese zwei Fälle sind aber ganz unterschiedlich, nämlich Serien,
die, wenn ich sie nennen darf, die Künstler von Artencom ihre Arbeit als Kunst,
nicht nur als Betrieb oder zum Profit.
Im Vergleich zu How to Sell Drugs Online ist der Moritz mit seinem Ego befasst.
Und meinetwegen haben echte Superhelden wie aus den Marvel-Filmen dieses existenzielle
Problem nicht. Probleme.
Was ist das Richtige? Ist das illegal?
Vielleicht Batman, aber sonst sehe ich es nicht.
Und ja, ist das, was ich mache, Kunst oder kreativ? Mhm.
Also ich finde, es hat noch einen anderen Aspekt bei The Billion Dollar Code. Also.
Wenn ich mir so die frühen Hackerfilme angucke, von denen ich bestimmt mehr
gesehen habe als sozusagen die neuzeitlichen, dann fällt halt auf,
dass es kein Berufsbildhacker gibt.
Es sind mehr so Autodidakten und irgendwie so Wunderkinder oder sie haben irgendwelche
speziellen Fähigkeiten.
Und heute gibt es einen Berufsbildhacker.
Es gibt eine ganze Szene, die aus verschiedenen Sichtungen beruflich tut.
Und mittlerweile auch in aufgefächerter Form.
Das sind ja nun beileibe nicht nur Hacker, die im Auftrag zum Beispiel in Systeme
einbrechen, weil der Besitzer der Systeme sie dazu auffordert oder so,
sondern es ist ja auch eine ganze Beratungsbranche mittlerweile.
Also Leuten helfen in der Defensive gegen Angriffen, in der Analyse von Angriffen.
Also heute gibt es ja nicht ein Berufsbild und ich finde so langsam sickert
es auch in diese in diese Film-Welt ein und da ist für mich The Billion Dollar
Code mal ein Beispiel, das wird nämlich, trotzdem, Arthur, kommt jetzt bestimmt
nicht gerade ein typischer,
Typischer Fall, das ist von Company, aber es hat ein Company.
Aber ich wollte gerade fragen, ist das noch Hacking im Sinne von,
wie man auch fragen kann, ist etwas noch Indie oder ist etwas noch Punk?
Also wenn ich für eine Billion Dollar Company irgendwie wie Computer-Defense-Macher,
bin ich dann noch ein Hacker oder ist das sozusagen so, wie zu sagen,
die späten Toten Hosen sind Punk?
Ich würde das klar bejahen, aber das liegt natürlich auch daran,
dass die Leute Hacker kennen, die das heute faktisch tun.
Egal, ob sie jetzt für eine kleinere Klitsche arbeiten oder für eine große Klitsche.
Meine persönliche Meinung ist, wenn du in der Defense bist, dann bist du schon ein Hacker.
Okay, weil ich hatte das mediale Bild, das fiktionale Bild vom Hacker ist immer
auch das der Unabhängigkeit.
Und die Frage ist, ist es dann noch gegeben, wenn man... Naja,
genau, das ist die Frage sozusagen.
Ist das noch so und wird das dementsprechend oder ist das einfach ein altes
Bild, was nicht mehr so ist?
William, was sagst du denn? Also in den Filmen, wenn die Hauptfigur versucht,
etwas allein zu schaffen, kommt es immer zum Katastrophen.
Also man braucht die Hacker-Freunde, um zu kollaborieren.
Deswegen würde ich euch fragen, ob diese Entwicklung positive Wirkung hat,
dass man jetzt kollaborativer wird und dass das Hacken verbessert?
Oder gibt es noch Einzelgänger, die alles allein zu schaffen versuchen?
Ich glaube eigentlich, dass es die noch nie gab. Wenn man sich die frühe Hackerethik
ansieht, auch die, die es schon vor dem TTC gab, also also sozusagen Steven
Levy im Original, war ja eigentlich diese Teilewissen immer dabei.
Und das ist, glaube ich, auch tatsächlich enorm wichtig.
Aber wenn man es jetzt wieder bezieht auf die heutige Hackerwelt,
dann ist das in jeder Hinsicht professionalisierte Arbeitsteilung.
Denn keiner kann die Fähigkeit alleine haben, auch nicht mehr in der Defensive.
Also die Professionalisierung in diesem Hackerfeld, die ist natürlich genau
mit dieser Arbeitsteilung verbunden und mit dem Information Sharing.
Aber auf dieser sozusagen ehrenamtlichen Ebene in Hacker-Szenen,
bevor das irgendwie mal ein Berufsbild wurde, war das glaube ich schon immer drin.
Also bevor der CTC angefangen hat, die Hacker-Ethik sozusagen in Deutsch umzuschreiben,
war das ja schon Teil. Würde ich zumindest so sehen.
Kasper guckt so im Mittel. Ja, ich denke darüber nach. Ich glaube,
es hängt halt sehr stark mit der Technikgeschichte zusammen.
Also in den 80er, 90er Jahren war es schwer, Informationen zu teilen,
einfach auf rein technologischer Basis.
Und heutzutage ist es schwer, Informationen nicht zu teilen.
Ja, aber heute musst du sie teilen, um Komplexität herzunehmen. Ja, genau.
Also ich meine, damit wollte ich erst mal sagen, heutzutage ist es der Normalfall,
sowas wie GitHub zu benutzen, ein Tool, um Code zu hosten.
Das ist eine bekannte Plattform und da können mehrere EntwicklerInnen gleichzeitig
an Code arbeiten. Das ist so ein quasi Standard, den benutzen viele.
Das wäre vor 30 Jahren schwierig gewesen, so zu arbeiten, auch wenn es solche Ansätze gab.
Und deswegen sind die Tools heute da und gleichzeitig werden sie benötigt,
weil wenn an einem Hack gearbeitet wird, wir können ja mal ein Beispiel geben,
auf dem letzten Kongress wurde gezeigt,
wie ein Zug wieder reanimiert wurde, sehr spannend,
weil das ein hochkomplexes Ding war.
Und da mussten aber mehrere Personen daran arbeiten,
weil das die technische Kompetenz einer Person überfordert, weil eine muss sich
sehr gut mit Hardware auskennen, eine mit bestimmten Komponenten von Software,
weil Software- und Hardwareprojekte so komplex sind, dass mehrere Personen daran arbeiten müssen.
Ein wunderbares Beispiel. Ja, oder? Das passt gut, genau.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du es sehen würdest. Du kennst sicherlich,
ich frage jetzt Will, sicherlich auch diese frühe Form der Hacker-Ethik und
ob das nicht schon immer mit dabei war, dass man gar nicht alleine kann,
sondern quasi kollaborieren muss.
Ja, und in den Filmen gibt es immer eine Visionärin, würde ich sagen, ein Robin Hood.
Aber ja, der fiktive Robin Hood braucht auch seine Räuberbande,
um erfolgreich zu sein, um dem Publikum zu helfen.
Aber jetzt klingt es gerade so, als wäre ein Hacker im Film sozusagen immer
Teil einer Bande und ich überlege jetzt gerade, ist das wirklich so oder nur
in den Filmen so, wo das im Mittelpunkt steht?
Ich hatte ja ganz am Anfang noch sozusagen diese Vermutung gehabt,
es gibt den Hacker als Sidekick, also wie in Die Hard 4 oder so.
Aber da sind die schon immer Teil einer dann im Film Unsichtbaren,
aber es ist immer Teil, dass die klar sind, sozusagen Teil einer Welt,
wo sie auch eine Subkultur.
Genau, Teil einer Subkultur.
Ja stimmt, das Wort Subkultur ist heute noch nicht gefallen.
Ja, Gott sei Dank haben wir das gesagt.
Ich habe aber noch eine andere Frage und zwar mein Eindruck von Hacker-Filmen
ist immer, dass die immer auch,
also wir reden jetzt immer über deren primäre Elemente, also dem Umgang mit
Rechenmaschinen und dem Widerstand gegen ein System und dem Regelbruch und so weiter und so fort.
Ich habe aber so ein zweitnämliches Gefühl, Hacker in Filmen sind grundsätzlich auch Leute,
die irgendwie noch eine Übersetzungshilfe für den Rest der Menschheit brauchen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt sehr oft noch, dass die Hackerfigur noch eine Figur
an der Seite hat, die dafür zuständig ist, mit dem Rest der Gesellschaft zu interagieren.
Also gerade so, als wäre der Hacker auch eine komische Maschine,
die von der Gesellschaft bedient werden müsste.
Und das ist selbst in dem Film, also jetzt wieder Spoiler, selbst in dem Film Who Am I,
das ist ja eine Geschichte von vier Hackern und da gibt es einen,
der ist sozusagen immer die Schnittstelle zu den ganzen sozialen Fertigkeiten
und da stellt sich am Ende heraus, der ist gar kein echter in Anführungszeichen
Hacker, weil er gar nicht programmieren kann, sondern nur ein Skript-Kiddy ist,
wie er von sich selbst sagt.
Also jemand, der sozusagen nur Dinge kopiert und nicht selber das wirklich kann.
Und ist das auch eine Gemeinschaft, die ihr von, also in der Hacker-Erzählung
in Filmen seht, nämlich dass der Hacker so ein bisschen als sozial unbedarft dargestellt wird,
also als ob es gerade so einen Zusammenhang gäbe zwischen ich verstehe Computer,
deswegen verstehe ich Menschen nicht.
Ist das was, was Hacker-Filme und Film-Hacker erzählen?
Doch, doch. In 23 in Who Am I gibt es Hauptfiguren, die sozusagen zu fern in
den Himmel gegangen sind.
Und sie brauchen Nebenfiguren, Sidekick-Happer, die sie zurück in die Welt bringen.
Und es ist andersrum in Billion Dollar Code.
Also die Nebenfigur braucht die Hilfe der Hauptfigur, um sein existenzielles Problem zu lösen.
Ich gebe einfach an euch noch weiter zu dem, was Willi mir gerade gesagt hat,
dass der Hacker also immer jemanden im Prinzip braucht. Seht ihr das auch so?
Und ist das nicht Teil der Identität eines Genies, dass wenn man so viel weiß,
hat man Probleme, zurechtzukommen mit der Menschheit?
Ah, das stimmt. Das Geniale haben wir, glaube ich, auch noch nicht angesprochen.
Also ich versuche das gerade durch so Filmbeispiele mir durch den Kopf gehen
zu lassen. Die Frage ist für mich jetzt, kommt der Hacker oder die Hackerin
alleine in der Welt zurecht oder nicht?
Also muss jemand dabei sein? Und es gibt auf jeden Fall Hacker,
die irgendjemanden brauchen, der sie durchleitet. Das ist ja auch ein bisschen
ein Klischee, der Nerd, der irgendwie nicht so richtig weiß.
Es gibt aber auch extrem selbstbewusste Charaktere.
Wir hatten vorhin über Lisbeth Salander gesprochen.
Die kommt zurecht. Die kommen echt zurecht. Genau.
Auf ihre Art. Ja, das macht sie sogar. Auf ihre Art.
Aber sie kommt zurecht. Ja, also ja, aber ich frage mich schon,
ob hier sozusagen eine Erzählung tradiert wird, die man auch gerne benutzt,
weil sie halt das Erzählen einfacher macht.
Also wenn ich in einem Film eine Genie-Figur habe oder jemand,
der sozusagen die Schnittstelle zum komplexen System ist, wenn ich dem dann
sozusagen wieder eine Schwäche anhängen kann, dann ist das ja was,
das macht das Erzählerische einfach.
Er wird dann eben nicht so sehr zum Superheld und gleichzeitig tradiert das
ja das Klischee vom weltfremden Technik-Nerd, der irgendwie sozial so ein bisschen inept ist.
Von daher frage ich mich schon, ob das narrative Faulheit auch ist,
das sozusagen immer weiter zu tradieren.
Ja, aber ich glaube auch realweltlich kann es ja oft irgendwie so eine...
Also so eine Genialität zugeschrieben oder jedenfalls mehr als notwendig bewundert,
was sie mit Computern können.
Also ich erlebe schon gerade so bei Leuten, die eine gewisse Ehrfurcht vor Technik
haben, das ist ja relativ verbreitet, dass Menschen auch eine gewisse Angst
vor Technik haben oder sich ein bisschen ohnmächtig fühlen,
dass derjenige, der diese Technik beherrscht, überhöht wird.
Das erlebe ich in der Realität auch.
Insofern spiegelt sich da glaube ich nur wieder, warum sollen Filmemacher das
anders sehen als viele Menschen in der Realität und es gibt so einen Übersprung.
Dadurch, dass Hacker auch in den früheren Filmen immer so als genial und so
als mit übermäßigen Fähigkeiten dargestellt werden, reproduziert sich das ja auch.
Auch in der Realität, finde ich. Also ich muss ganz kurz eine Anekdote aus meinem Leben erzählen.
Ich habe ein paar Jahre auf dem Dorf gelebt jetzt in den letzten Jahren und
mir wurde irgendwann zugetragen, dass über mich dort die Geschichte kursierte,
man solle es sich nicht mit mir verscherzen, weil ich könnte dann die Konten der Person hacken.
Weil ich halt irgendwie, naja, weil ich irgendwie was mit Technik und das war
so, und ich konnte auch nie erklären, was ich als Dayjob arbeite.
Und weil du hast gerade gesprochen von so einer narrativen Faulheit und Constanze
hat glaube ich gegengehalten und gesagt, nee, das ist einfach die Geschichte,
die in der Gesellschaft kursiert.
Deswegen ist es nicht die Faulheit, sondern das Wiedererzählen einer Geschichte
und ich würde da mitgehen, dass das Tatsache, also die Mär geht um.
Ja, aber genau, aber das würde ich so, das ist das, was ich mit narrativer Faulheit meine.
Also ich tradiere das Klischee weiter, statt mir die Mühe zu,
also gerade im deutschen, wir haben ja festgestellt, im deutschen Bezug ist
immer sozusagen die Lust an der Authentizität.
Also das soll also was haben. Und wenn ich dann so sagen, aber bei der einen Sache sage,
na gut, aber es ist schon irgendwie sehr praktisch, wenn auch ich erzählen kann,
wie irgendwie wir nerdy und unbeholfen die
in sozialen situationen sind das ist ja weiß
ich nicht würde würde ich mir mehr wünschen gehen wir
kurz zurück zu den archetypen die markus
am anfang erwähnt hat in dieser drei
fälle dass eine figur die sehr schüchtern
ist und eine die ganz charismatisch ist
und ja kommt auf den
fall an welcher existenzielle probleme
hat aber man merkt ja das ist ganz symbiotisch man
braucht einander also in 23 braucht
karl koch seinen freund david in who am i braucht benjamin den max und in billion
dollar code ist das carsten jury und ja wenn sie sich trennen dann schaffen
sie nichts vielleicht versteige ich mich jetzt Aber ich habe auch manchmal sozusagen
so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass wenn man Hacker als Helden sind,
dass das auch so ein Vehikel ist.
Man könnte es sogar transportieren im Sinne, vielleicht hat die Welt Angst vor Hackern.
Also wenn die jetzt nicht nur die digitale Welt kontrollieren,
sondern auch noch sozial empathisch fit sind, dann hält die ja niemand mehr auf.
Dann sind wir alle verloren. Hacker als Weltherrschaft. Also es gibt so eine
Figur, die mir einfällt, in Passwort Swordfish.
Der Hacker, der sieht cool aus, gespielt von John Travolta, glaube ich.
Robert Redford meinst du, oder? Nee, weder noch. Ach, das ist nicht,
nee, der heißt... Nee, nein, John Travolta war völlig falsch,
aber ich sag mal so ein schicker Amerikaner.
Ja, ja, der ist richtig. Ein schnittiger John Travolta, so ein schnittiger Typ jedenfalls.
Und es gibt eine Szene, die sexuell auch sehr explizit ist, wo,
sagen wir mal, an ihm, ich umschreibe es jetzt mal jugendfrei,
sexuelle Handlungen vollzogen werden, während er einen Hack ausführen muss unter Zeitdruck.
Hugh Jackman? Ja, das kann sein. Genau. Ja, ja, ja.
Wie komme ich denn auf John Travolta? Das ist doch egal. Der spielt auch mit.
Der spielt mit in dem Film. Aber der ist nicht der Hacker. Nee, nee, genau.
Der spielt mit, aber genau. Ich habe die beiden verwechselt,
mein Namensgedächtnis.
Jedenfalls sieht er ganz anders aus als die Hacker vorher.
Wie ja auch in Matrix, die dann schon ein bisschen anders aussehen.
Und das war aber auch eine verstörende Hackerfigur dadurch, tatsächlich.
Jetzt muss ich aber auch Angelina Jolie sagen. Oh, einer der besten Hackerfilme
überhaupt jetzt. Genau, also nur um es mal gesagt zu haben.
Ja, sag mal den Film nochmal. Der hieß… Hackers, oder?
Hacker, ne? Und Hackers, weißt du, wie der hieß? Mit Angelina Jolie, der Hackerfilm?
Was, du hast den Hackerfilm mit Angelina Jolie nicht gesehen?
Es ist ja kein deutscher Hackerfilm. Ach stimmt, ja, ist ja kein deutscher Hackerfilm.
Also, ich finde, einer der besten amerikanischen Hackerfilme,
einfach weil er super lustig ist. ist einfach Hackers mit Angelina Jolie.
Hack the Planet ist einfach kurzweilig. Ja, und es ist auch kulturell interessant.
Ja, und es gibt eine tolle Hack-Szene auch. Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, wie zeigt man Hacken.
Da gibt es einen Hacker-Battle, der, glaube ich, so dargestellt wird,
dass ein Roboterarm immer Datasetten oder so aus einem Schrank rausholt, um die Wette.
Also da versucht man das durch so Robotertätigkeiten irgendwie darzustellen.
Um auf Sprecherzugriff zu kommen. Ja genau, also das ist auf jeden Fall,
kann man den sich angucken.
Vielleicht ist das dann wirklich auch die Stelle, wo wir dahin zurückkommen
können, zu der Darstellung, zu der guten oder schlechten Darstellung von Hux
in Filmen und jetzt auch sozusagen vielleicht auf das deutsche,
auf deutsche Filme und Fernsehen zurückgegriffen.
William, was ist denn für dich sozusagen die beste Analogie für was da im Computer
passiert, wie sie in Filmen dargestellt wird?
Wenigstens diese Angst, dass man die ganze Welt beherrscht und dass es Bösewichten
im Internet gibt, kommt vor allem in der Serie You Are Wanted vor.
Das ist mit Matthias Schweighöfer, der ist ganz prominent in Deutschland.
Aber ja, die Serie schafft es zu zeigen, wie integriert alles heutzutage ist.
Und wenn was integriert ist, dann ist es Teil dieses Systems und dadurch ganz hackbar.
Ich fürchte, wir haben jetzt ein bisschen aneinander vorbeigeredet,
weil was ich meinte ist sozusagen die visuelle Repräsentation davon, wie gehackt wird.
Also wir hatten ja schon gesprochen über die U-Bahn, die das Darknet ist in Who Am I?
Und die Frage sozusagen, was daran, also an visuellen Repräsentationen von Hacking,
was dir da aufgefallen ist, was besonders gut gelungen ist.
Und ja, ich möchte nachher noch sozusagen zu den Fails kommen.
Jetzt aber erstmal, was ist eine gute Repräsentation von Hacking?
Ach so. Ja, wenn man auf dem Schirm Programmiersprache im Computer sieht,
ist das für normale Menschen so, okay, der Computer ist ganz kaputt und hat ein Virus darauf.
Und ja, so wird es oftmals in jenen Filmen dargestellt.
Also man versteht nicht, was auf dem Schirm passiert oder was der Schirm sagt.
Man weiß nur, okay, ein Hacker hat das kaputt gemacht, sozusagen.
Aber hast du eine Analogie sozusagen, wo das eine gute Repräsentation hat?
Also vielleicht sozusagen ein zweites Beispiel zu der U-Bahn,
die das Darknet darstellt?
Also wo da künstlerische Formen gefunden sind, die das nacherlebbar,
nachvollziehbar machen?
In 23 zum Beispiel ist man so am Telefon und man hat ein ganz altes Laptop dabei.
Und man sieht auf dem Schirm, es gibt Lokalitäten und es gibt Nummern und Zahlen,
die zeigen, ja, man hat reingehackt und dann kommt es zu Problemen.
Ich finde die Darstellungen in 23 ganz realistisch, aber auch, ja, Zeitgenossen.
Zeitgenössischer. MARKUS TRANTOW Ja, mir fallen zwei gute Beispiele ein.
Ich finde eine Sache wurde gut in Wargames dargestellt aus den 80er Jahren,
nämlich das Wardialing, also das Durchprobieren von Telefonnummern,
um auf Daten zuzugreifen.
Das wurde einfach gezeigt, das sah sehr schick aus.
Und in den USA ist wohl zu Weihnachten dann auch der Verkauf von Computermodems
enorm in die Höhe gestiegen, was auch spannend ist in Bezug auf der Wechselwirkung
von Hacker, Szene und Film. Vielen Dank.
Und dann noch ein anderes Beispiel, das vielleicht ein bisschen überraschend
ist, Tron Legacy, eine Disney-Produktion.
Da gibt es, Konstanze zieht die Augenbrauen hoch, da gibt es ein Hacker-Battle,
wo also zwei Hacker sich bekriegen und auf der einen Seite sieht man,
was der für Befehle eingibt im Computer.
Und auf der Kommandozeile am Computer gibt es Befehle, die einfach auf Englisch
sind und die sind sehr gut nachvollziehbar.
Zum Beispiel Befehle wie Kill.
Und in dieser Szene werden diese Befehle eingegeben und auch wenn Zuschauer
nicht wirklich wissen, was dort passiert,
ist es einerseits relativ realistisch, weil man benutzt diese Befehle,
um zum Beispiel Programme zum Absturz zu bringen oder zu beenden.
Und andererseits versteht sie auch jemand, der nicht programmieren kann.
Und es gibt dazu auch einen Blogpost, wo der Visual Artist von Tron Legacy erklärt,
wie es zu dieser Szene gekommen ist.
Der hat sich da einfach eingemischt und hat gesagt, ah, lass uns das mal so machen.
Und deswegen gibt es diese eine Szene in Tron Legacy, die ich wirklich richtig gut fand.
Also wenn ich jetzt ein Computer wäre, würde ich diese Antwort zurückgeben,
weil ich ja nach deutschen Filmen gesagt habe, aber ich will mal nicht so sein.
Constanze? Ja, ich werde keine Zähne hinzufügen, aber ich muss ein Element des
Huckings, was nie im Film dargestellt wird, hier unbedingt mal anmerken.
Nee, nee, nee, zu den Fails kommen wir gleich.
Ist kein Fail, das ist ein strukturelles, kulturelles Problem.
Ja, aber Leute, ich bin wirklich entsetzt.
Okay, dann schließe ich mich wohl an 23. Die Zeitgenössische Darstellung finde
ich heute schon wieder doppelt interessant, weil sie nicht nur das Hucking gut
darstellt, sondern weil sie auch,
die Computertechnik dieser Zeit cool darstellt. Die ja viele einfach jetzt,
wenn die heute sich den Film angucken, nicht mehr kennen können.
Aber du hast ja, oder ihr habt ja beraten bei Who Am I? Ich noch nicht,
das war vor meiner Zeit. Bei Who Am I?
Ja, achso. So genau, das müsste ja, wenn jeder sozusagen Mitarbeiter oder du,
muss das ja besonders gut gelungen sein, oder?
Oder andersrum gefragt, wie groß war denn die Diskrepanz zwischen deiner Beratung
und das, was du nachher im Film gesehen hast?
Nee, ich würde das nicht so sehen, wie es bei 23 war, wo das ja eine richtig
enge Zusammenarbeit war und da ja auch einfach, da waren Menschen,
die dabei waren, die darüber berichtet haben.
Das ist ja anders, als wenn du ein Screenplay bekommst oder eine Vorform war
das sogar und dann setzt du dich mit denen mal hin und da hältst,
die klopfen so ein bisschen ab, was ist denn daran realistisch oder war das einfach unsinnig so.
Und davon gab es mehrere Iterationen, aber das ist keine Filmberatung in dem
Sinne, wie das bei 23 stattgefunden hat, sondern das ist mehr so ein, wie kann man das machen.
Aber trotzdem, also du sagst, das war sehr im Vorfeld, aber trotzdem hast du
dann im Film Fails gesehen, wo du dann gedacht hast, boah, ich hab doch gesagt,
das sollt ihr nicht so machen oder haben die alles umgesetzt?
Also ich persönlich fand die, anders als das Kaspar vorhin gesagt hat,
diese künstlerische Umsetzung mit den Tubes nicht so gelungen. Warum?
Also ich fand das schon den Aspekt, wie man Anonymität jemanden begreiflich
macht, der jetzt irgendwie selber noch nie Darknet benutzt hat oder so, das schon.
Aber die Wiederholung war mir zu häufig.
Es soll natürlich künstlerisch auch ein Muster sein, wenn man wieder erkennt,
das ist mir irgendwie auch klar, das kann ich kognitiv verstehen,
aber mir ging es auf den Kranz.
Aber so jetzt will man sich von den fels kommen
wollen kassel eine szene mitgebracht aus dem film oder die ja ich genau
ich habe aus dem vorfeld kurz gesprochen und da hatte ich gesagt ich hab doch
hier in roma ich lese mal kurz einen dialog aus hohem ei vor benjamin war der
eine und wie ist der andere der anrax max ok also wenn er sagt also max fragt
benjamin hey was was was Was hast du gemacht?
Was hast du verbrochen? Er sagt, Benjamin, ich habe einen Uniserver gehackt.
Max, und wie bist du durch deren Access-Control gekommen?
Benjamin, mit einem Zero-Day-Exploit. Jetzt muss ich kurz pausieren.
Dieser Dialog macht Sinn.
Kurz Zero-Day-Exploit? Genau, ich erkläre kurz. Also erstmal der eine sagt,
ich habe einen Uniserver gehabt, kann man sich vorstellen.
Das andere, wie bist du durch deren Access-Control gekommen?
Also wie bist du irgendwie durch deren Firewall, was auch immer,
Benutzer, okay, versteht man auch. Mit dem Zero-Day-Exploit heißt,
er hat einen Crack verwendet, der noch nicht bekannt ist.
Eine Sicherheitslücke. Eine Sicherheitslücke, die noch nicht bekannt ist öffentlich.
Das nennt sich Zero-Day-Exploit. Bis dahin ist es gut.
Und jetzt antwortet Max darauf, du kannst Maschinensprache lesen, einfach so.
Und dieser Satz macht auf so vielen Ebenen keinen Sinn.
Das ist mir wirklich, weil ich dachte so, endlich mal ein realistischer Dia. Nee, doch nicht.
Und ja, genau. Ich habe seit ihr davon erzählt, dass du versuchst zu sagen,
so eine Analogie zu finden, ich scheitere so ein bisschen, aber es ist so ähnlich,
wie jemand sagt, boah, du hast diesen Kuchen gebacken und dann sagt der andere,
ja, ich weiß, wie man Trecker auseinanderbaut.
Es hat ganz am Rande was damit zu tun, aber es ist...
Aber ich habe immerhin ein Erklärungsmodell dafür.
Ihr könntet mir vorstellen, wenn ich weiß, was ein Zero-Day-Exploit ist,
aber die Null sieht in geschriebener Form, der denkt an Nullen und Einsen und der denkt an Maschinen.
Oh mein Gott! Ja, wegen 0 und 0 und 1.
Ich möchte aber hier betonen, dass ich in diesem Stadion nichts mehr mit dem
Screenplay zu tun hatte und keine Verantwortung übernehme.
Kannst du dich an die Szene erinnern?
Das ist halt Diskrepanz zwischen der Realität und dem Realismus im Film.
Das kommt auch in der Serie You Are Wanted vor.
Also ganz plausibel, das Auto der Hauptfigur wird gehackt und er verliert die
Kontrolle des Wagens komplett.
Ich finde das plausibel, wenn man an Teslas denkt, die in San Francisco ohne einen Fahrer sind.
Aber dann gibt es fragwürdigere Hacks, zum Beispiel wenn ein Aufzug in einem
Krankenhaus nicht mehr funktioniert, weil man das gehackt hat.
Ist das vielleicht übertrieben.
Und es gibt in all diesen Filmen Überschreibungen.
Also ich fand You Are Wanted unerträglich, was die Hack-Szenen angeht.
Also eine nach der anderen hat mir körperliche Schmerzen bereitet.
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass wir heute so viel darüber reden.
Das müssen wir nochmal ein bisschen... You Are Wanted ist eine Amazon Prime-Serie,
glaube ich, gewesen. Eine deutsche Auftragsposition, wo Matthias Hacker für
den Bösewicht, glaube ich, spielt. Nee, nee, nee.
Der ist der Betroffene. Es geht um so einen Typen, der wird halt sozusagen von
einem bösen Hacker unter Druck gesetzt, und da wollte ich übrigens fragen,
William, ist das für dich,
eine deutsche Produktion, also siehst du die im selben Kanon wie all die anderen
Sachen, die du beschrieben hast, oder versuchen hier deutsche,
US-amerikanisches Hackerfernsehen nachzumachen?
Ja, das ist auch die Frage mit Billion Dollar Code, aber ich sehe die beide
ähnlich, wie sie umgehen und tja, ich finde das immer noch als Realismus.
Also inwiefern das überdramatisiert wird, das ist eine andere Frage,
aber es versucht halt die Realität darzustellen und sogar in der deutschen Kultur.
Also ja, das gehört meinetwegen zu der Genre.
Ich muss jetzt unbedingt Kasper fragen, ob er eine Szene konkret in Erinnerung
hat, die ihm körperliche Schmerzen bereitet hat.
Weißt du jetzt eine? Ja, ich habe mir jetzt nochmal die erste Folge einfach
nochmal angeguckt, um es aufzufrischen.
Das fängt schon damit an, ich spoile jetzt ein bisschen, aber nicht zu sehr.
Der Hacker guckt über sowas wie so ein Alexa-Screen-Bildschirm in die Wohnung
rein und da steht das Kind und der Hacker guckt dadurch, dass das Kind sich,
also da geht der Bildschirm an, die Webcam und dann sieht das Kind sich aber
selber. Und ich frage mich, was soll das technisch?
Also was, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, das würde ein Hacker nie machen,
das macht technisch keinen Sinn, ja, vielleicht filmisch.
Das finde ich total interessant, weil der, also das ist in dir sozusagen so
ein Widerspruchspuls, weil ich aus einer rein erzählerischen Perspektive,
dem Hacker sozusagen, das weiß man zumindest am Anfang nicht,
ob der ein Ziel hat, sondern der will ja nur Stress machen. machen.
Und das finde ich sozusagen, einem Kind ein Gerät anzumachen,
das hat sie also nicht selber bedient, und sich dann selber zu zeigen,
finde ich eine ganz valide Form, um so eine Art Horror in diesen,
das kann man so mit Gasleitung auch verbinden. Was hast du da gemacht?
Ich habe gar nichts gemacht, aber wieso ist dann die Kamera an?
Das fand ich total plausibel.
So habe ich das noch nicht gesehen, das ist interessant.
Und ansonsten gibt es da immer so diese Szenen, wo Schweighöfer an seinem Rechner
sitzt und dann immer so ganz viele Fenster so dramatisch auf und zu gehen.
Und ich denke so, Ja, echt jetzt, aber es gibt auch gute Szenen da drin,
nämlich wo der dann seinen Computer neu aufsetzt, einfach wirklich Windows neu
installiert und davon genervt ist.
Also da finde ich auch den Charakter nachvollziehbar. Der denkt,
ich bin gehackt worden, ich installiere Windows neu, schön, hat er gelesen, ein Computerbild.
Aber wenn er wirklich gehackt wird gerade immer, das ist jedes Mal so,
da sind wir filmisch einfach schon weiter gewesen.
Das fand ich sehr retro, was sie da gezeigt haben.
Mich würde wirklich interessieren, wie das hinter den Kulissen aussieht,
inwieweit da Leute berichtig beraten und dann irgendjemand anders sagt,
nee, wir machen das trotzdem so. Falls ihr Einblick gehabt habt,
schreibt es in die Kommentare oder uns eine Mail. Oder beauftragt uns, wir beraten euch.
Also ja, es ist dasselbe Genre wie die anderen, aber ja, es ist noch mehr Richtung
Hollywood, auf jeden Fall.
Und deswegen kann es mit den Ängsten eines heutzutagigen Publikums spielen. Ja, das stimmt.
Und wie verändern vielleicht die Darstellung auch die Hackerwelt selber?
Das finde ich, vielleicht kann auch von euch einer was sagen.
Also gibt es mittlerweile Hacker-Manierismen, die vielleicht davon kommen,
dass Hacker in den Medien oder in den fiktiven Medien sozusagen auf so eine
Art und Weise dargestellt werden?
Welche Wechselwirkungen gibt es zwischen der Darstellung von Hackern in Filmen
und TV und den Hosenwelt-HackerInnen?
Ja, müsste man euch fragen, ob die Darstellung von Hackern euch beeinflusst irgendwie.
Und ja, also das Streaming macht doch eine Wirkung.
Also wenn man in Netflix etwas aus Deutschland schauen darf,
dann hat man ja eine andere Position, die man überlegen könnte.
Mir fällt eine Frage nach, Entschuldigung, die ich vergessen habe zu stellen.
Und William, das wollte ich nämlich dich vor allem wegen der Außenperspektive
fragen, sind hackende Personen im deutschen Film und Fernsehen nur Männer?
Nein, aber die Hauptfiguren doch. Also man sieht in You Are Wanted,
es gibt Frauen im Zimmer und das ist der Fall bei all diesen Beispielen,
dass es Frauen im Zimmer gibt.
Und ja, doch in 23 hat Koch eine Beziehung mit einer, die immer da ist und teilnimmt.
Aber ja, leider gibt es keine Hauptfigurinnen bisher in solchen Filmen.
Also in Dokumentarfilmen doch, aber in, sagen wir, Featurefilmen gibt es keine
Frau in der Hauptrolle als Hacker bisher.
Ja, es gibt ja diesen Bechtel-Test, der ist ja mittlerweile auch im Stritten,
aber sozusagen so als Daumenregel, finde ich, kann man immer noch kurz gucken,
der sagt, der die Frage stellt, gibt es in Filmen sozusagen Frauen,
die sich miteinander unterhalten über was anderes als Männer?
Und ich fürchte sozusagen für Hackerinnen im deutschen Film und Fernsehen ist
die Antwort da ganz eindeutig nein.
Wenn es keine gibt, wie sollen sie sich unterhalten? Genau, sie sind halt nur
im Zimmer, sie sind halt Beiwerk.
Kasper? Ja, würde ich auch. Also im deutschen Film nein. Da fällt euch dann einer in einem Ami?
Also gibt es, fällt euch jemand? naja habt
ihr schon genannt die angelina jolie und aus
sind sie glasen verfilmung gar nicht ihr
habt keine ahnung wie oft darauf angesprochen wurde damals gab er zwei filme
davon unglaublich weil das so selten war ich habe ich habe war überschwemmt
von von presseanfragen als diese filme rauskommen da war ein zeitlicher versatz
also gibt übrigens schwedische oder skandinavische Produktion und eine Ami-Produktion, oder?
Genau. Die Schwedische ist besser. Die ist nicht auch, natürlich.
Man sollte auch die Serie erwähnen, Biohackers.
Das ist eine deutsche Serie mit einer Frau in der Hauptrolle.
Sie experimentiert, aber nicht nur mit Computern, nicht mit Programmier-Sprache.
Der Bechtel-Test wird ja auch nicht bestanden, wenn es nur eine Frau als Hauptrolle gibt.
Das ist eben das Wichtige. Es muss ja nur eine zweite geben.
Sie könnte sich mit einer Nebenrolle über was anhören. Genau,
aber wenn es einen Namen haben und sie müssen sich unterhalten und nicht über
Männer. Und da wird es tatsächlich dann schwieriger.
Wie würdet ihr Trinity, also weil Matrix ja sozusagen auch so,
also würdet ihr Trinity, also den Charakter von Carrie Ann Moss in Matrix sozusagen
als weibliche Hackerin oder als Beiwerk?
Och, die ist schon Hacker, aber reden tut sie nicht viel. Na,
beides, weil auch wieder sie, und das soll jetzt nicht abfällig klingen,
sondern wirklich als filmische Beschreibung, sie ist halt auch...
Sexuelles Objekt für den Hauptcharakter nachher. Also er erobert sie ja,
also doch wieder so ein ganz klassischer Plot.
Das heißt, sie ist nicht eine unabhängige Nicht-Sex-Partnerin.
Jaja, aber Keanu Reeves ist bitteschön auch echt ein Sexobjekt. Aber was für jetzt?
Also ich würde es ja nun mal nicht unerwähnt lassen. Es ist nicht so mein Fall, aber...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir möchten in die Kings, der Sprecherin des Chaos
Computer Groups, an dieser Stelle nicht weiter eingehen, sondern zurück zur
Frage kommen, welche Welche Wechselwirkungen ihr zwischen der Darstellung von
Hackern, wie wir jetzt gelernt haben, im deutschen Film und Fernsehen seht mit dem Rest der Welt?
Für mich sind relativ deutliche, manchmal in den letzten Jahren,
Vorträge darüber gehalten, die fünf schlimmsten Mythen zu debunken über Hacker.
Weil ich glaube, dass es eine starke Rückwirkung gibt, aber weniger von diesen deutschen Filmen.
Ich glaube, dass die deutschen Filme unter Deutschen immer noch sehr viel weniger
gesehen werden, als die Hollywood-Schinken.
Und vor allen Dingen die Hollywood-Vorabendserien, also diese CSI-Hacking,
ist glaube ich das Allerschlimmste.
Diese, I need three minutes and I'm in und egal wo. Also wisst ihr,
diese. Zu zweit an einer Tastatur. Ja, total.
Und mehrere Dinge, also wenn man darüber ernsthaft spricht und Leute sich für
Hacker interessieren und zum Beispiel einen einladen, sodass man darüber spricht,
dann kann man diese Klischees aus den Filmen immer wieder abrufen,
weil Leute halt in ihrer Lebenswelt mit keinem Hacker in Kontakt kommen und
es ihre einzige Darstellung ist.
Für mich ist die extrem wirkungsmächtig nach wie vor. Darf ich jetzt endlich mal sagen, was da fehlt?
Was mich so ärgert seit Jahren? Darf ich jetzt sagen?
Niemand liest da mal ein Manual. Niemand. Es regt mich so auf.
Also das Hackerleben besteht in hohem Maße davon, sich mal mit den Details eines
technischen Systems auseinanderzusetzen. Dazu muss man diese blöden Manuals
lesen. Und nie taucht es auch nur auf.
Es wird nicht mal erwähnt in den Filmen. Es regt mich auf. Read the Manual.
Read the fucking Manual. Ja, du hast recht. Jawohl, das wollte ich jetzt hier
endlich mal gesagt haben. Okay.
Also auch im MyMakker-Leben, das ist ja nicht nur Software, das ist auch Hardware.
Du musst dich mit diesem System, mit den Spezifikationen beschäftigen.
Macht überhaupt keinen Spaß, das zu lesen.
Und man muss auch lang, also wie gesagt, dieser ganze Vorlaufprozess findet ohnehin statt.
Die sind immer schon alle auf einem gewissen Level. Man muss sich nie einarbeiten
ins System. Das regt mich schon seit Jahren um.
So fertig, fertig aufgeregt. Kaspar?
Ich würde es ähnlich beantworten wie Constanze. das indirekt oder direkt eben
getan hat, ja, es gibt eine Wechselwirkung auf jeden Fall zwischen filmischer Welt und Realwelt,
aber die besteht auch in Deutschland nur sehr wenig auf der Basis von deutschen Produktionen.
Und Filme wie 23 und so sind keine Blockbuster,
die irgendwie die Wohnungen vollgestopft haben mit Menschen,
die geguckt haben, sondern die Klischees und die Sachen kommen vielmehr aus
großen internationalen Produktionen,
die aber auch eben aus Schweden kommen können, ja, plötzlich.
Aber die deutschen Filme sind eher für mich immer etwas Retrospektives,
das sich mit der eigenen Geschichte befasst, wie zum Beispiel auch diese RAF-Feature-Filme.
Also da würde ich eher die deutsche Filmkultur sehen.
Wobei wir einen dabei hatten, den man hier als Blockbuster bezeichnen kann.
Also Who Am I war auch kommerziellen Erfolg.
Aber war das in Deutschland auch? Ja. Aber war er kommerziellen Erfolg oder
war es sozusagen so ein richtiger Top Ten? Also hat William in seinem Buch geschrieben, stimmt das nicht?
Tja, keiner war ganz erfolgreich, besonders am Anfang, aber dass man immer noch 23.
Sieht oder sehen möchte, oder es ist wieder aufgetaucht, ja,
finde ich ganz interessant.
Das kann man natürlich auf zwei Arten lesen, man kann sagen,
das ist ein so guter Film, dass man ihn jetzt immer noch sehen will,
man könnte auch sagen, seitdem ist halt einfach nichts gekommen,
was dem das Wasser reichen kann, das heißt, es ist auch auch so ein bisschen Dürre hier irgendwie.
Zum Schluss habe ich noch zwei Fragen.
Die erste ist, ob ihr kurz einen Tipp abgeben könnt, es ist ja in der Medienwelt
oder generell in der Welt sozusagen, findet ja leider oft Amerikalisierung statt
und wir haben jetzt irgendwie You Are Wanted schon gesagt,
also das ist was, das orientiert sich halt sehr stark an Hollywood, auch Who Am I Come From,
glaubst du, William, vielleicht wird sich, du hast ja deutsches Film,
also Hacker in deutschen Film und Fernsehen als eigenständiges Gebiet untersucht,
glaubst du, dass es das in Zukunft auch noch geben wird?
Also dass Hacker in deutschen Film und Fernsehen sich so sehr unterscheiden
werden von US-amerikanischen Produktionen, dass sich das als Untersuchungsgebiet
lohnt oder wird sich das einfach angleichen, weil es sich besser verkauft?
Das ist eine große Frage und ich meine, dass die Antworten von Kaspar und Constanze
ganz schön das dargestellt haben.
Und Berlin ist auch schon amerikanisiert.
Noch stärker in den letzten zehn Jahren, kann man sagen.
Also, nein, es wird noch deutsche Vorstellungen von Hacker geben,
aber das wird auch zum anderen Teil immer internationaler.
Vielleicht nicht amerikanisiert, sondern internationalisiert.
Ich glaube auch, dass diese, jetzt schon mehrfach ist es dir gefallen,
Netflix-Produktionen oder Amazon Prime oder so, ich denke, die machen was.
Meine Beobachtung ist, dass die meisten dieser deutschen Produktionen sind Co-Produktionen.
Das heißt, da gibt es auch eine organisatorische Zusammenarbeit und auch eine,
die sich auf ein internationales Publikum richtet, weil sie sich von vornherein vermarkten.
Wenn ihr euch anguckt, was zum Beispiel auch jetzt die aktuellen großen ARD-Produktionen
sind und Co-Produktionen, die mit technischen Themen zu tun haben.
Die sind in Englisch gedreht mit deutschen Schauspielern.
Das heißt, da gibt es ein Zugehen auf diese Märkte.
Haben wir eigentlich schon über Bollywood geredet?
Oder Nollywood? Na gut, also mein Eindruck ist, dass es auch von den...
Jetzt musst du kurz sagen, was das ist.
Bollywood, der größte Filmmarkt in Indien und Nollywood ist sozusagen das afrikanische Pendant.
Egal, also ich habe mich selber wieder unterbrochen.
Wir müssen jetzt noch mal ein eigenes Karius-Radio über Bollywood und Nollywood-Hackerfilme
machen. Aus meiner Sicht müssen wir dringend diesen Podcast fortführen,
weil wir auch nur wenige Aspekte ansprechen konnten. Wir müssen das unbedingt fortführen.
Und wisst ihr, wie wir das fortführen? Ich habe eine Idee, darf ich das live
hier on air sagen? Können wir ja im Zweifel rausschneiden.
Raushacken, Entschuldigung. Na ja, am spannendsten ist es doch letztlich so
wie in Williams Buch, wenn man es am einzelnen Film unter einer einzelnen Figur
festmacht. Also wenn man,
Sich ein konkretes Beispiel sucht und daran die Klischees oder Nicht-Klischees,
die da schon was Hacks, kulturelle festmacht.
Naja gut. Also ihr könnt schon mal gucken, ob hackercast.de noch frei ist,
vielleicht ist ja gerade ein neuer Podcast geboren worden.
Kaspar, wolltest du auch noch zur möglichen Amerikanisierung,
Internationalisierung von deutschen Hacker filmen? Ich fand schön,
was William gesagt hat, dass Berlin ja auch amerikanisiert wurde.
Als gebürtiger Berliner würde ich sagen, aua ja. Also es ist natürlich komisch
mit jemandem, der gerade in Amerika ist, das als etwas Schlechtes darzustellen.
Das dachte ich auch, das ist auch ein bisschen blöd. Aber ich glaube,
wir wissen alle, was gemeint ist. Als ich Billion Dollar Code geguckt habe,
war ich sehr berührt emotional, weil ich habe meine Jugend in den 90er Jahren gesehen.
Also ich war echt kurz, ich hatte so eine Träne im Knopfloch und habe so gesehen,
so Orte wie die Seabase und Hacker Club so vor Augen wieder in der Oranienburger
Straße und dachte so, Mann war das eine schöne Zeit hier, die war auch wirklich toll.
So und das war interessant das aber
in so einer produktion zu sehen ja also da bringt
das auch was gutes hervor weil auch das geld da ist um diese zeit wieder
aufleben zu lassen das kostet ja auch produktionsgelder das
alte berlin darzustellen aber so wie sich berlin verändert wird sich auch wird
werden sich auch die filmproduktion verändern dass das denke ich auch ja so
lange ja wenn ich sagen darf ja berlin ist noch meine lieblingsstadt also je
mehr die die Rolle eines deutschen Hackers sich ändert,
ich meine internationale,
desto mehr wird das bei den Filmen reflektiert.
Also die Filme sind eine Reflexion der Realität, auch wenn sie übertrieben sind.
Okay, so dann allerletzte Abschlussrunde mit der Abschlussfrage mit der Bitte um kurze Antwort.
Wenn man sich jetzt diesen Podcast angehört hat und vorher noch nicht,
also es nicht irgendwie gerade innerlich seine eigene Bibliothek durchgeht und
denkt, aha, sondern wenn man jetzt nur an das Thema einsteigen will, als Empfehlung und,
Vielleicht als positive Empfehlung, also nicht sozusagen schlimmster Hacker-Fehlfilm,
sondern der eine Hacker-Film, wo ihr sagt, wenn man einsteigen will,
Kasper zeigt, er möchte gerne drei Titel sagen, na gut,
aber ihr anderen müsst nicht drei sagen, also euer Lieblings-Hacker-Film oder
wenn es sein muss, eure drei Lieblings-Hacker-Filme oder Serien.
Dann Kasper, fang doch mal an. Okay, also ich muss einfach 23 sagen.
Das ist historisch auch interessant. Da lernt man was über Geschichte.
Ich finde Hackers aus Amerika ist einfach witzig. Das ist popkulturell wichtig.
Und einen Film möchte ich noch pitchen, den wir gar nicht genannt haben.
1987, Deutschland, der Film Peng, du bist tot, wo Rolf Zacher einen Hacker spielt
und der aber enorm interessant ist in der Darstellung von Hack.
Und den gibt es auf einer Videoplattform irgendwie umsonst zu gucken,
glaube ich, wenn man da irgendwie nach Peng, du bist tot googelt.
Also ich könnte mich bei den allen drei anschließen. Es liegt aber daran,
dass wir über Peng, du bist tot, man kennt schon mal den Sprachrahmen von langer Zeit.
Von den Büchern, die William ein Buch hat, würde ich glaube ich am ehesten The
Billion Dollar Code angucken. weil es eben auch ja, die Stadt ist da schön porträtiert,
die Charaktere haben eine gewisse Tiefe, also eine schöne Art, finde ich.
Ansonsten ich überlege gerade, ob ich noch einen Film kenne.
Also ich finde nicht uninteressant, wenn man sich ein bisschen für diese kulturelle
Hacker-Bild interessiert.
Die Matrix-Trilogie, ist das eine Trilogie? Ja, ich kenne nur drei.
Also die sich nochmal anzusehen, denn da ist ja auch dieses Konzept,
in was reinzuhaken, die Realität mit damit zu ändern, finde ich auch interessant.
Also, das war mal ein Blockbuster, aber ich glaube, dass jüngere Leute den heute
gar nicht mehr so kennen, weil der ist jetzt einfach so ein bisschen abgehangen.
Und ich finde, das lohnt sich, wenn man den ganzen Ballast von diesem religiösen
Überbau da wegdenkt, sich nochmal anzusehen, wie der Hacker da dargestellt ist,
wie unterschiedlich die Hacker sind. Finde ich persönlich nicht so schlecht.
Er ist halt alt. Ich tue mich schwer, weil ich bei Matrix bin ich immer so,
also guckt den ersten Teil, guckt Zusammenfassung für Teil 2 und 3 und guckt
den vierten Teil. Ich glaube, das ist alles, was man da gerade machen muss.
Ich finde von den Filmen aus dem Buch von Wilhelm, ich war total überrascht.
Ich hatte nämlich damals Who Am I ausgelassen, weil ich dachte,
das ist bestimmt ganz schlimm.
Ich habe den jetzt in der Vorbereitung der Sendung geguckt und es ist einfach
auch sehr ungesundes Action-Kino. Also das ist eine gute Abendunterhaltung,
wenn er mal die Füße hochlegen wollte und dass er ein bisschen Knall-Peng-Puff
macht. Das ist gut gelungen.
William, du musst anscheinend, wenn du es noch nicht getan hast,
Peng, du bist tot gucken. Habe ich jetzt so als Hausaufgabe von den anderen
beiden an dich mitvernommen.
Was sind denn deine Hackfilm-Empfehlungen?
Tja, wenn man nur aktuelle Filme oder aktuelles Fernsehen mag und nur etwas
aus der Jetzt-Zeit sehen möchte, dann auf jeden Fall Billion Dollar Code.
Ich finde den Vergleich zwischen Silicon Valley und Berlin super interessant. Muss man schauen.
Ansonsten, wenn man auch alte Filme mag, dann auf jeden Fall 23.
Die Gedanken sind frei, singen David und Karl auf einem Zug.
Also wenn man nur ein bisschen schon für die deutsche Geschichte sich interessiert,
dann gibt es so viele Filme. Ganz sehenswert.
Ja, also die beiden. War das eigentlich mit Berlin Babylon?
Ist das ein Hackerfilm? Nein, das sind ja nicht wirklich Hackerfiguren.
Es ist doch eine Situation.
Ja, meine Deutschstudentinnen in den USA schauen die Serie schon.
Ich habe auch vor, vielleicht über Dark zu schreiben. Also, ja. Ja.
Okay, dann vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr heute alle hier wart.
Vielen Dank, William, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast.
Dein Buch heißt Hackers as Heroes in German Film and Television.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht ganz billig, weil es ein wissenschaftliches Buch vor
allem ist, aber es ist lesenswert, das kann ich tatsächlich sagen.
Vielen lieben Dank, dass du da warst. Bitteschön. Vielen lieben Dank,
Kasper und Constanze, dass ihr da wart.
Und liebe HörerInnen, viel Spaß beim Gucken.
Ich verabschiede mich auch. Mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen
und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss!
Music.